[Music]
the helicopter lurched and rumbled as it
made its descent through the veran insk
mountain range conditions were harsh
with Fierce winds ripping Through The
Valleys at any point a blizzard
threatened to strike just about managing
to touchdown mobile task force Lambda 9
was glad to be out of the vehicle even
if it meant stepping into kneee snow
there were eight operatives in total
early reconnaissance suggested that they
were the only people present within a 5
km radius at least that's certainly what
they hoped L9 operatives 1 through six
all made their way up through the
mountain pass leaving seven and eight
guarding the chopper this was a simple
reconnaissance mission they would need
to search the bunker for any signs of
Life gather inel and get out hopefully
before the snowstorm hit all eight of
them were kitted out with the
foundation's kter grade Cutting Edge
anti-icing the operatives had all been
chosen carefully with L 9-1 the leader
being an experienced Soldier serving 11
years in the unit he had capable psionic
Powers himself and approached L 9-2 who
showed some of the same gifts all of a
sudden as the group rounded the final
pass and caught sight of the facility
both one and two experienced severe
migraines battered by the Russian wind
they had no choice but to get to the
bunker as fast as possible it looked
relatively unassuming a small concrete
slab sitting amongst the mountain
the six of them gathered around on
either side of the doors as number three
forced his way inside following standard
breaching Maneuvers the rest of the team
followed suit charging in through the
open doorway and immediately tipping
forward into an abyss they all landed
hard side by side on the slope some of
them rolling down clattering against
each other and eventually skidding to a
stop very gingerly the groups started to
get back to their feet and catch their
breath as the wind had been knocked out
out of all of them they weren't in a
research facility at all the Soviet
concrete walls they' been expecting the
old computers and the lab equipment were
all missing instead they were standing
in a void infinite and white with no
seeming end in any direction beneath
their feet and curling up above them was
an enormous double helix a rainbow of
colors weaving in and out of one another
it was like they had found themselves
standing on an enormous strand of DNA
floating all around them were glowing
orbs of light none of them could tell
how near or far these orbs were they
could have been close enough to reach
out and touch or they could have been on
the other side of the universe and
slowly one by one they noticed the
doorway that they had come in through it
was perpendicular to the double helix
and floating about 3 m above their heads
through it they could see the snowy
Russian Mountains their only chance of
Escape four murmured something about
needing to leave one argued back at him
they had no idea whether that door was
real or an illusion they had no idea if
they would even be able to pass through
it besides it was 3 m above their heads
and floating out over the void it was
risky but for didn't care much about
receiving permission taking a few steps
back further down the double helix to
get a good runup he braced himself and
sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster he let
out a petrified scream that sent the
other operatives cowering there was no
bottom at least not as far as they could
see or hear for's body just got smaller
and smaller and his screams quieter and
quieter for several minutes until the
agents couldn't hear him anymore and yet
inside the heads of one and two the
psionic members of the group that scre
screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through the
West Berlin train station he shaved his
head the night before and trimmed his
beard down to a thick mustache dark
sunglasses covered his eyes and a fedora
was stepped forward he hoped that his
limp was convincing as he shuffled his
way through the crowds one advantage of
wearing dark sunglasses in the middle of
winter was that he could constantly scan
the faces of those around him looking
for anybody who looked Russian his train
had been delayed an hour outside of
Berlin the train had ground to a halt
German police officers had walked the
length of the carriages checking
everyone's tickets and passports it felt
like an eternity the man was too old by
this point to attempt to run away
besides running through rural Germany in
the snow didn't sound like the best plan
so he stuck to his cover story and hoped
against hope that the fake passport he
bought would be convincing enough
fortunately for him the officer checked
it he looked to be about 18 years old
the man doubted that the boy would know
a Russian passport if it was signed by
Nikita kushev himself but shuffling
through the station his feeling of
unease grew Russian deserters had been
poisoned all around him for the prior 15
years a number of his own colleagues had
mysteriously gone missing after feeling
disenfranchised by the Soviet agenda it
was such a high-profile Target that
there was no way the kg wasn't actively
hunting him down at that very moment he
clutched the briefcase tightly and made
his way out of the station his plan had
been to call a taxi but now the prospect
of being alone in an anonymous vehicle
with only one other person terrified him
his best protection would be to stay out
in the open as much as possible he would
walk to the British Embassy or rather
he'd pretend to limp there Lambda 9
operatives number seven and 8 stood by
the helicopter shivering their team had
been missing for hours now and they
could see the blizzard slowly covering
the mountain range like a blanket before
long it would reach them if their
helicopter got buried by anything more
than a couple of inches all hopes of
evacuating back to base would be dashed
as soon as their team had gone through
the doors into the facility all radio
contact with them had been cut off the
foundation had suspected that the bunker
would be heavily insulated but if that
were the case surely one of them would
have stepped outside to resume radio
contact and report what they had found
so far then all of a sudden seven went
limp he remained standing but his head
and shoulders slumped forward as if he'd
fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long Aid was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello8 can you hear me
it's one are you there the conversation
moved quickly somehow one had been able
to reach out to Seven's mind and
temporarily take control in order to use
him as a mouthpiece to communicate with
the foundation over the radio this kind
of contact would normally have been well
beyond what one would have been capable
of but he explained that as soon as they
had entered the facility both he and two
had felt their powers growing
immeasurably the foundation asked for a
situation report and one updated them
about what had happened to four trying
to escape through the door he jumped and
fell through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had start
started to hear his screams physically
not psionically and he had fallen past
them just off to their right almost
within touching distance having decided
that it was too risky to attempt an
escape as four had done the group of
them made the decision to travel further
down into the facility descending along
the Helix for the next 3 hours s is
unresponsive he stands there limp in the
snow hunched forward and not speaking
despite eight and the foundation's best
attempts to wake him command we found
something the Helix branches off a bit
there's a doorway there I can see inside
it looks like a lab of some kind we can
walk to it hopefully it's a way out
command sent authorization for them to
proceed and so they did one reported
that it appeared that they were back in
the real world the abstract shapes and
colors the infinite void was gone they
were in a Soviet research lab there was
medical equipment everywhere syringes
and jars full of well maybe it's best
not to know what was in there them as
Lambda 9 walked through the facility
checking every corner before rounding
out they felt a profound sense of unease
surely enough that feeling was warranted
rounding the corner one found some human
remains the man appeared to have been a
researcher at one point his brains were
now stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was a project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second world
war their death toll eclipsed that of
any other country Iceman had witnessed
it all so when Stalin had come to him
with the task of creating an ultra
powerful psychic weapon something that
could convert the entire world
population to adopt Marxism leninism the
man had his reservations activating a
device like that could trigger a war
even deadlier than either of the two
already EXP experienced that Century he
was part of Gru division P the Russian
arm of Highly classified experimental
research conferring with his team they
devised a plan they would argue they
needed absolute secrecy to carry out
their work even away from the watching
eyes of the KGB rather than create a
weapon they would create a tool for
peace instead of promoting the values of
Communism they would create a psychic
tool to dampen Humanity's inclination
towards violence and aggression their
method would be brutal but un necessary
evil in short their theory was the
psychic mind is often limited by the
human body a young child could have
incredible psychic potential but their
physical limitations would hold them
back from exercising it therefore they
needed to separate mind from body and
they had just the trick for that
traumatic disassociation they would take
a young gifted psychic and tear out
their mind in order to transfer that
mind into the body of a a controllable
Avatar Iceman explained that none of
them could have expected how much fate
would look favorably on them just 2
years prior the KGB had captured and
brought in a set of triplets for them
the triplets were incredibly rare
conjoined at both the head and the Torso
with three arms and six legs it was a
miracle they were still alive so Iceman
and his team set to work immediately
they dosed the triplets up with as many
mind-altering chemicals as they could
physically endure before ruting them for
prolonged periods whilst reading antiv
violent manifestos to them it worked the
triplets mind disassociated and the
Soviets were able to capture it Iceman
was not forthcoming about what they did
with the mind or where they transferred
it all he explained was that it worked
they took the weapon to the norog gulag
50,000 of the most vicious criminals
known to men Luther murderer Psychopaths
dropped their makeshift knives and
refused to move an inch even as we threw
the the gates of the camp wide open we
did that the final test was on Nikita
crev and John F Kennedy from thousands
of kilometers away they activated
project Redline and influenced the two
world leaders at the height of the Cuban
Missile Crisis war was averted but cruv
was Furious he removed the entire team
killing a number of them and began to
weaponize project Redline if they could
fire it at an advancing Army they'd
never lose a single soldier ever again
to do this it needed to be strong longer
they were to implant the Consciousness
into another subject torture them
further and disassociate again
amplifying the psychic abilities mobile
task force Lambda 9 were stuck in the
facility the blizzard had been so strong
that seven and 8 had to return to base
the previous night and come back having
spent a night lost in wandering through
the Helix descending deeper and deeper
the team had noticed that the world
around them was getting darker
periodically they could hear Force
screaming and falling past them once
again before dropping out of sight sight
again beneath them they had tried to
catch him to pull him back but he was
always just Out Of Reach desperate to be
saved seven and 8 returned and their
psychic puppet radio contact was resumed
with command the team found another door
searching through it they were horrified
to find their own corpses floating in
the air in front of them dressed up in
lab coats just like the scientists from
the levels above them their brains were
stretching out and lying together in
some kind of web yet further down the
Helix they found another door one and
three decided to go inside leaving the
rest of the team standing on the Helix
ready to catch four if he fell past
again this time two was in contact with
command through his psychic link to the
men by the chopper he soon reported
hearing Four's screams getting closer
and closer the group stood around ready
to catch him there he is I can see him
he's definitely Falling Towards us yeah
I see it too command there's something
up with for it looks like he's spread
eagled his arms are stretched out he's
he's screaming it's not getting louder
it's getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time 1 and three returned from
scouting out the room they were alone
one couldn't even sense the presence of
any of their squadmates anymore they had
no option but to continue to descend the
Helix into the darkness the smell of
burning flesh filled their noses The
Echoes of death were all around them
voices cried out in pain and fear and
then new voices speaking in Russian cut
over the top stop it give in don't
resist resisting is bad you will be
punished if you resist begin electrical
discharge 500 volts 3 amps increase
voltage every minute the operatives had
no choice but to listen to the memory of
the triplets being tortured not just the
sounds but the emotions that flood them
those weren't someone else's memories
anymore they were becoming their own and
just as they saw into the mind of the
triplet the triplet saw them in return
command it's trying to open me up like
it did everyone else but I can see into
it it's learning from us it knows all
about me the squad the foundation
they're almost on me it's it's the
conjunction the scientists the monsters
that made this thing the ones it knew
before it died was that they wanted it
to conjunct it wants to make us part of
it don't come back here it wants to make
the whole world part of it and at that
moment the entirety of mobile task force
Lambda 9 dropped dead in that same
moment a multicolored sphere of energy 5
km wide appeared over the facility
dwarfing the mountains around it
designated SCP 2664 daa for years the
foundation dropped psionically dampening
materials and psionically stumped
d-class Personnel into the sphere in
hopes of slowing its growth no other
containment measures could be acted upon
that was until 1300 hours on the 25th of
December 2000 Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa
suddenly fluctuated releasing an
enormous amount of psionic energy that
resulted in the brain death of all
humans within a 200 km radius the
following day at 1700 hours a global
cult Coalition satellite launched a
spherical payload right into the heart
of SCP 2664 daa for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just just as suddenly as
it had appeared SCP 2664 daa disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the foundation was able to
recover the payload it launched into the
atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirmed no abnormal radioactive
or psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long may it stay that way
the diver screams A Silent Scream as the
giant Squid's beak digs into his skin
it's many grasping tentacles grabbing
him and holding him in place nearby his
fellow divers are driven half mad with
Terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the MC and
strange Russian voices speaking in their
heads nobody can help them they're down
too deep too consumed by the darkness
and the pressure of the sea they're now
at the mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage what followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 as United States citizens
feared they were teetering on the brink
of nuclear war in July of 1968 the
Soviet Union the United Kingdom and the
United States came together to sign the
treaty on the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons agre to abandon their
pursuit of increasing nuclear power and
turn their focus to disarmament but
several months before the treaty was
signed the Soviet government was dealing
in Weaponry far more dangerous than
nuclear missiles something the other
world powers knew nothing about these
deadly secrets were hidden aboard a
submarine known as SCP 741 SCP 741 is
the underwater wreckage of a Soviet
submarine that sank in March of 1968 and
came into the custody of the SCP
Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in the wreck at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hle was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moan
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described in incident report
1741a divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be it
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fix it on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
area a30 laughed off his jumpiness
agreed that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
Vini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerge from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like like
a person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation too and began to panic
some checked their nitrogen levels
believing it to be some sort of nitrogen
Narcosis While others pointed out that
they couldn't all be suffering from
nitrogen Narcosis at the same time the
unknown voice continued speaking saying
help me it is getting hard to breathe
the divers debated what to do next
questioning whether what they were
seeing was even real when all at once
the humanoid figure vanished from sight
the divers attempted to shake off the
startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a 5 m
long squid swimming around the wreckage
its presence startled the divers at
first particularly those closest to the
animal but the others encouraged them to
ignore it citing the fact that there are
no records of these squid attacking
humans so they did continuing their work
as the squids circled them with apparent
care curiosity a27 spotted an unusual
shell below the wreckage notably large
and difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US governments indicate
that the submarine was being used to
transport some sort of secret cargo
though the specifics of this cargo are
still unknown there is reason to believe
that it differed from any type of
nuclear or chemical Weaponry on a date
redacted from official files the scps
basti was patrolling the area around SCP
741 when it sonar detected some unknown
entity approaching SCP 741 from the
south at a pace of 46 knots the crew
compared the acoustic signature of the
contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basti attempted to reach the contact via
sonab Bui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
cross crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an underseen missile launch
and basti responded with the utmost
urgency the ship broke away from its
original area and fired a type 53
torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the bisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 m and a
velocity of .92 Mach the missiles did
not emit any detectable radar nor did
they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the basti both of the
missiles were engaged by bti's 3K N5
kinsol surfac to- aair missiles and
cachan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 M and 210 M from
Impact respectively after the missiles
were neutralized the Hostile vessel
could be heard engaging in evasive
maneuvers at this point there were four
closely spaced explosions and the sound
of a submarine disintegrating the IDE
identity of the attacker as well as its
intention toward SCP 741 have not yet
been determined the incident resulted in
the foundation research team suggesting
an expansion of the acoustic sensor net
as well as additional Patrol and defense
assets placed in the area additionally
they advised an acquisition of undersea
retaliatory capability the incident was
classified incident 1741 DC the sonar
recordings from the scps bisti during
incident 1741 DC were Tak for further
analysis by the research team the
in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remain protected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff the redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crewmen we buried Just
Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in the thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at v preparent as spies wind
up owing each other favors after a while
and they denied it vehemently not your
usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redact
doctor do you have any idea what it
takes to make a bioweapons researcher
sick now that wasn't what really bugged
me though what really kept me awake at
night was the KGB file that fell into
our hands they mentioned a covert op by
the Soviet military against an internal
unnamed faction to get rid of a quote
terrifying weapons that even the Soviet
Union can't safely control they wanted
to lose it whatever it was or maybe fob
it off onto the US of course of course
that all came to light right before the
Iron Curtain fell and given the
atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too Lan and you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been inter feared with
in any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets SCP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left Al alone
down there at the bottom of the sea some
say that SCP 2102 was a mistake an
Abomination created by an accident of
Medical Science maybe those people are
right maybe there's much more to it than
that either way they don't know the full
story how could they they weren't there
they weren't there all the way back in
1972 but Dr paval zukal was the earliest
moments the events that directly pred
eded SCP 22's creation began on March
2nd the wind was carrying an unforgiving
freezing bite with it as zukal made his
way to the Institute of experimental
medicine zav in Czechoslovakia with the
cold war between the USSR and the United
States underway there was already an air
of secrecy on both sides Espionage and
intelligence gathering operations were
rampant bringing with them paranoia and
distrust there was no way of knowing if
someone was a double- ag agent leaking
information to the west but while the
governments of Russia America and their
various respective allies and enemies
scrambled for control and had massed
obscene quantities of nuclear arms in
secret there were even more cogs turning
hidden in the deepest darkest Shadows
the SCP foundation's long-standing
rivalry with various other groups of
Interest was well known among any with a
high enough security clearance most of
these groups were radicals or outliers
despite possessing knowledge of
anomalies or even being directly linked
to them a lot of gois were independent
of any world government but for decades
the foundation had been aware of a
directly competing establishment
effectively a parallel of their own
organization on the other side of the
globe they were known as Gru division p
a USSR equivalent of the SCP Foundation
themselves it is unclear based on what
was recovered from Dr zuk's Personal
Diary if he had been directly scouted by
Gru division P for their project in
Czechoslovakia given the air of secrecy
engulfing the USSR at the time it is
possible that pavl himself had no
inclination that division P was even
involved in the project due to take
place at The Institute of experimental
medicine he might have suspected but
with no way of knowing for sure
similarly there was no way zukal could
have known where the project would lead
what he would have a hand in creating
the initial few weeks after his arrival
at the instit were Rocky to say the
least zukal along with a team of
scientists and technicians working on
orders direct from Moscow had to contend
with unreliable equipment and difficulty
getting electricity to power the project
eventually after clearing those initial
hurdles testing could begin but what was
the goal of this mysterious project well
through zakol Gru division p and the
Kremlin were chasing something the
scientific world has been trying to
accomplish for decades something that
could change the very landscape of not
only the Cold War but the entirety of
modern medicine the secrets of cellular
regeneration unlocking that would in
theory enable them to create the world's
very first unkillable super soldier and
hey it definitely wouldn't be the
craziest secret operation carried out by
a world superpower during the Cold War
the CIA spent Millions turning a cat
into a listening device and training it
to infiltrate enemy headquarters this
so-called acous Kitty was struck and
killed by a random van during its first
mission compared to that a cell
regenerating super soldier was
positively sensible with a worldwide
nuclear arms race already underway
perhaps the Project's ultimate goal was
to produce an entire Army of these
self-regenerating troops with something
like that in their hands the USSR would
have the manpower to reinforce their
nuclear Arsenal and potentially even
soldiers capable of surviving and
healing from the effects of an atomic IC
blast on the 5th of May
1972 the first of the Project's human
test subjects began to show promising
results they underwent physical trauma
at the hands of zukal and the other
scientists only for their bodies to
react much faster than the ordinary
healing process would allow rapid
clotting took place in the affected
areas preventing the subjects from
bleeding out however this quickly went
Ary the clots turned into severe lesions
realizing this had occurred thanks to
maau one of the other project scientist
administering too much neodium zukal
chastised his colleague vowing him to
drag him to Moscow personally if another
mistake like that ever took place again
unfortunately by the last few days of
June Dr zukal and his team were no
closer to success every subject that
underwent testing succumbed to the same
necrosis reducing the amount of neodium
had only made the reaction worse
something paval couldn't allow M to know
without the risk of it being held over
his head for the remainder of of the
project in every instance the doctors
were able to trigger rapid cell division
50 times faster than that which occurs
in the ordinary healing process of human
beings but the biggest drawback was that
this division would quickly become
uncontrollable it was creating enough
new matter on a cellular level that it
would choke each test subject in its own
excess waste as you might expect Dr
zukal noted this in his diary that this
process wasn't a pretty sight come mid
August
1972 the project scientists decided they
needed a test subject with more
resilience than the average person and a
suitable candidate was provided he was a
counterrevolutionary who had been
sentenced to 15 years in a uranium mine
as a punishment detail despite such an
extended period of time under the harsh
conditions of the mine and the close
proximity to a radioactive element such
as uranium the man managed to survive
unscathed upon closer examination this
new guinea pig referred to as x16 had a
rate of healing twice as fast as that of
an average man perhaps it was a random
genetic abnormality that made x16 this
way or maybe it was a result of his
extensive time in the uranium mines
either way it made him the perfect new
subject for zuk's experiments initially
subject x6's preliminary testing results
looked promising the wound healing
process was actually taking place now
instead of resulting in necrosis or
aborting it as it had with the earlier
experiments in fact Dr zukal seemed to
think x16 was healing almost too quickly
but nevertheless testing continued
although not without a different type of
problem the questionable morality of
what they were doing began to set in for
paval causing him nights of endless
tossing and turning unable to sleep as
he reflected on what he'd done x16 had
managed to survive for much longer than
the earlier test subjects but it was
clear that the torture this man had to
endure was exactly ing a heavy toll
every day the doctors would lacerate him
time and time again recording the
results and every day he survived only
for the cycle to begin again the next
day for his own part zukal was
conflicted on the one hand the results
of the testing were proving successful
lasting far longer and working far more
effectively than they had in the past
and yet on the other it came at the cost
of one man's continued suffering to make
matters worse a valid no way of voicing
his concerns to any of his team any
questioning of his orders or the
Project's methods would have been viewed
by Gru division p and the KGB as
sedition and treason earning the good
doctor a one-way ticket to a goog or if
he was lucky a clean shot to the back of
the head from an agent's pistol often
morality is sacrificed for the greater
good in the pursuit of the advancement
of science or a nation's goals but now
that the project was showing results
with x16 now that it was real
what they were doing still weighed
heavily on Dr zuk's conscience then on
October 15th
1972 the final piece of the puzzle
seemed to become clear by introducing
the correct amount of stabilizing agent
into the serum they had concocted zukal
and his team had perfected the
composition upon administering this
newly completed version of the solution
the doctor noted in his diary that
subject x16 was responding well at least
medically the subject was responding
well it was clear that the continuous
experimentation he had been subjected to
was causing uncooperative behavior in
x16 but so close to the cusp of
achieving the Project's goals Dr zukal
was quick to cast aside his previous
doubts about the ethics of their methods
they were so close to Victory so close
to the project being over that it no
longer mattered how Cooperative x16 was
being but 2 weeks and 4 days later just
as the project was nearing its end goal
disaster struck mu Dr Elena OVA was one
of the scientists on zuk's team who had
primarily helped when examining the
early cell divisions those that were
leading to necrosis and causing test
subjects to produce too much excessive
genetic material Alena had made a
startling Discovery and immediately
brought it to Dr zukal in a distraught
show of panic the cell samples they had
used to test their serum were now
gaining mass seemingly from nowhere just
like the earlier experiments the effects
were working almost too well causing an
overabundance of cellular regeneration
to the point where the cells couldn't
stop producing masses of waste genetic
material when zukal brought Elena's
findings to doctors ssard and one jury T
finko the project heads assigned by
division P they were quick to disregard
it as an error determining to press on
with the project to meet their deadline
over the course of the following weeks
up to late November zukal was trying to
determine determin what was causing this
change it was clear that unless he and
Elena could resolve the issues with the
serum subject x16 would be a total
failure but time was running out with
their superiors at Gru division p and
the Kremlin expecting results by early
December under untold amounts of
pressure and subsequent stress Dr paval
zukal found himself losing time unable
to sleep to the point where he was
drifting off whenever he was on the
verge of a breakthrough by the end Elena
was the only member of the team trying
to help him methodically figure out what
had gone wrong the deadline for the
project arrived on December 2nd
1972 paval didn't sleep all night
leading up to it knowing he would have
to present a functioning super soldier
to GRU division p in the best case he
was risking being accused of negligent
failure forced to restart the project
from scratch making his months of hard
work redundant but worst case scenario
zukal could be charged with treason for
having not completed the task he was
selected for on the 2nd of December he
wrote I really don't know which is
better tomorrow is a Day Too nobody
knows if Dr pelu call lived to see that
tomorrow his final diary entry was made
on the day SCP 2102 was born for months
the SCP Foundation had operatives
embedded within the Czechoslovakian
government as part of innumerable Cold
War Espionage Gathering efforts during
that time their agents had gathered
enough intelligence to make the
foundation aware of Gru division P
Project based at The Institute of
experimental medicine and that the
scientists there were looking to unlock
the secret of Rapid cellular
regeneration someone possibly even one
of zuk's team had managed to infiltrate
the project and had leaked documents to
the SCP Foundation explaining what was
going on in Czechoslovakia the plan was
that the foundation would move in in
secret of course to extract and contain
test subject x16 in January of 196 73
that day would never come to fruition
though on the 2nd of December only a
month before they had planned to act the
foundation became aware of a catastrophe
occurring at The Institute of
experimental medicine one of their
agents in Czechoslovakia alerted them to
a disturbance that had caused civilians
and scientists alike to run from The
Institute in fear for their lives
something had gotten loose and the
foundation had to act fast luckily a
reconnaissance team was stationed in
Eastern Europe members of various mile
task forces who had been spying on Gru
division p and the rest of the USSR
moving quickly the Recon team was
deployed to chakia led by a field
commander named merik they were given
the objective to determine the cause of
the situation and if possible recover
its anomalous Source mer and the Recon
team arrived on site at the institute's
grounds the entrance to the bunker which
had been housing the project was left
wide open with not a soul in sight as
the team progressed further Merrick
couldn't help but noticed a pungent
smell permeating the labs and offices
that they passed Foundation command
urged their operatives to proceed
cautiously and recover any paperwork
they could among the logistical
documents was a diary belonging to one
of the scientists although the name
paval zukal on the cover was no longer
legible forever lost the further he and
the other MTF agents progressed the
worse the smell got they located an
elevator deciding to take it down to the
lower levels of the bunker one by one
the team f m in mer radioing command
command any seismic activity in the area
he asked uh not that we know of Merck
came the foundation's reply why I uh I
think I just felt something move down
there the elevator had barely descended
a foot before it hit something stopping
in an instant as Merck tried once again
to contact Foundation command that same
something came tearing through the
elevator floor over the radio the SCP
Foundation were treated to a cacophony
of screeching tearing metal a along with
the screams of their own men what
Merrick and his team had encountered may
have once been a man perhaps someone
subjected to Cruelty and torture but now
all they saw was an amorphous flushing
Mass immediately the Recon team opened
fire engaging what they assumed was a
raging monster it probably never
occurred to them that they might have
just wanted to be free after years of
imprisonment followed by months of
horrendous experiments minutes later
Merck was able to get in contact with
command again locked in a heated battle
with the entity but every round fired
every shot their guns landed nothing was
having any effect whenever Merck dealt
damage to the creature part of it seemed
to grow faster and faster each time
their guns were useless unable to stop
the expanding monstrous test subject
even grenades thrown by the MTF
operatives causing multiple explosions
did little to stop the entity in its
tracks listening in over the radio
knowing they had few options left the
SCP Foundation dispatched a pair of f4
Phantoms long range supersonic fighter
jets equipped with a payload of m47 A1
napom incendiary bombs with Merck and
his men almost on the ropes command
issued an order to retreat they fled the
bunker only to feel the ground shake
beneath their feet the monster had
reached the top soil still coming after
them Jones one of the foundation's
agents was Pulled Under the encroaching
shapeless Mass crushed to death as it
continued its Pursuit utterly horrified
at the sight and speed of the creature
Merck started begging command over the
radio to get its fighter jets to the
scene 6 minutes later the sound of twin
turbine engine shot through the air
followed by the whistle of bombs caring
down towards the ground in a second
merik his team and the creature were
engulfed in a fiery explosion the heat
proving enough to cauterize the fleshy
Abominations expanding tissue ever since
December
1972 The Entity now designated as SCP
2102 has been housed at site 122
contained by the SCP Foundation they
keep it in a modified cell restrained at
all times with its hands and feet and
padded sleeves this is done in order to
prevent the risk of injury either
accidental or intentional given both SCP
22's anomalous properties and its
self-destructive Tendencies its body is
covered in scars both from its previous
Escape attempts back when it was known
as subject x16 and from burns from the
F4 Phantoms NE Palm payload these
particular injuries seared the entity's
ears mouth and eyes closed rendering it
deaf mute and blind if SCP 2102 ever
suffers any form of external injury its
anomalous properties will trigger the
creature as you might have guessed
possessed an advanced form of cellular
healing able to regenerate from all
wounds inflicted on it however the
process was never perfected it still
works too well so well that SCP 2102
cells don't know what when to stop
instead they continue producing bodily
tissue expanding its mass into every
available space without a halt the
process can be slowed if an obstacle is
introduced boxing in the exponentially
growing tissue however any object or
person and its path is eventually
crushed under the mounting pressure at
present the foundation still has no idea
how much SCP 2102 tissue could expand
potentially even posing a risk to the
entire world if left unchecked there is
only only one Surefire way to stop the
creatures healing it can only be halted
by cauterizing the open wound with
intense heat it's literally a Surefire
solution SCP 2102 is a result of the
good Dr zuk's work combined with his and
Gru division P's willingness to put
aside their morality they didn't create
an undying regenerating super soldier
for the USSR as they had intended
instead all they accomplished was
turning a tortured man into a monster an
Abomination endlessly tormented by the
experiments performed on him not quite
as useful on the battlefield is it cast
your mine back to the height of the Cold
War the ever accelerating nuclear arms
race brought us closer than ever before
to making the nightmare of nuclear
Armageddon a terrifying reality the two
main parties in this conflict are the
United States and Soviet Union each
amassing huge amounts of nuclear
warheads and jumping on any available
Advantage they can over their enemies
what you may not know is that in order
to detect an impending attack from the
United States the Soviets developed what
would become known to the West as the
dead hand but this experimental piece of
technology also had another name SCP
1984 it is no secret that the Soviet
Union feared the threat of US nuclear
strikes an invasion just as much as the
US feared an attack from them so SCP
1984 was created to act as a deterrence
me mechanism specifically against secure
second strikes secure second strikes
were both a deterrent and overwhelming
concern during the Cold War referring to
a country's ability after suffering an
initial nuclear attack to still
retaliate firing on their enemy and
causing Untold damage with their own
arsenal of nuclear weapons the Soviet
Union knew that any action they made
that could be perceived as an attack on
United States soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation and that if
they fired First America would return
fire and potentially annihilate them
with a second strike SCP 1984 was to be
an automated system that would activate
in response to the destruction of the
soviet's main command and control
structure given that the Dead Hand was
created during the80s you might be
forgiven for expecting a nuclear
detection system built at this point in
history to consist of various sensors
connected to a computer network but you
have also probably already realized that
if this was the case then the foundation
wouldn't be so interested in it in
actuality SCP 1984 is a fully autonomous
entity rather than a network of sensors
for detecting incoming nuclear strikes
or a computer capable of initiating a
second strike perhaps what makes the
foundation more interested in the Dead
Hand is that it is both self-aware and
links simultaneously to every single one
of Russia's nuclear launch sites not
only this but SCP 1984 also has has
direct access to every single one of the
atomic weapons stockpiled by the Soviet
Union during the Cold War and is capable
of launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles at a moment's notice in short
SCP 1984 could very easily and
horrifyingly quickly trigger an allout
nuclear war resulting in the extinction
of all life on Earth no wonder the
foundation considers the dead hands such
a massive threat SCP 1984 itself
actually consists of the preserved
remains of a Russian soldier by the name
of Sergeant morat chernikov who was
killed during the Soviet Afghan war in
1982 most of the official documentation
of chernov's existence has been expunged
by the Russian Federation and he is only
referred to in fragmented documents
recovered by the foundation that
referred to a project December these
remains serve as the location of a semi
sentient Consciousness that has been
classified as SCP
19841 when it remains dormant and is not
interfered with SCP
19841 has the ability to receive and
process any signal broadcast to it and
is able to decipher information combined
in any signal it picks up however when
global Military tensions start to climb
especially when those tensions affect
the Russian Federation or what were once
the satellite states of the former
Soviet Union The Entity begins to
manifest itself in the physical world
and usually in various strange in
different ways SCP
19841 has been known to appear in the
real world in forms such as a humanoid
outline or a bright red Spectre taking
the shape of a child with its legs cut
off regardless of which shape it appears
in it is when the Dead Hand manifests in
a more physical form that the wider
scope of its abilities become clear as
mentioned previously it can influence
and even launch nuclear weapons
overriding their command systems and
bypassing launch sequences after
appearing fully scp1
19841 will travel at speeds of up to 140
kilm an hour directly to the nearest
military installation capable of
launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles once it reaches its destination
SCP
19841 will immediately attempt to
override the necessary systems to
initiate a launch after firing missiles
at their predetermined targets scp1
19841 will hastily traveled to another
facility housing nuclear ordinance
repeating the process until it has
successfully launched all of Russia's
Atomic weapons when engaged the physical
manifestation of SCP 1984 is highly
aggressive and will lethally defend
itself against anyone that it observes
trying to interfere with it or stop it
from causing a nuclear launch the entity
has displayed the ability to disrupt the
nervous system causing excruciating pain
and debilitating damage to human beings
it its only known weakness if any is a
susceptibility to microwave radiation
although exposure to this does not seem
to cause any lasting damage to SCP 1984
instead only temporarily disorienting
its physical form as for the origins of
SCP 1984 the Soviet Union's official
liaison with the SCP Foundation offered
some clarity on this ironically during
early 1984 the liaison a doctor named
Sergey described inform regarding the
Dead Hand as being of grave importance
to the continued survival of the human
race seeing as he was referring to an
enemy that could single-handedly launch
the Soviet Union's entire nuclear
Arsenal he certainly had a point a top
secet Conference was held in s Avo
between the foundation's 05 Council and
officials from both the USSR and the
United States using the 1984 Winter
Olympics as cover avoiding too many
questions about several Nations high-
ranking State officials being in the
same place at once the 05 Council was
then given full in-depth information
about the Dead Hand something they had
previously assumed was a more
conventional form of nuclear deterrence
SCP 1984 was far more and worse far out
of the control of the Russian government
it was revealed that the entity had been
designated outside the original
specifications given to those who
developed it initially the Soviets had
intended for the Dead Hand to be solely
used as a secure second strike response
response if the leaders of the Soviet
Union were killed SCP 1984 would react
in kind to Russia's enemies launching
back all of the ussr's nuclear missiles
in retaliation this is more likely where
the Dead Hand nickname comes from
hearkening to the idea of a dead man's
switch picture that you had been
mortally wounded by your worst enemy
shot in the stomach and laying on the
ground rapidly bleeding out you know
that there is no chance you will survive
but you cannot afford to let your enemy
get away what they don't know is that
you rigged the entire building around
you both with explosives with your dying
breath you activate the Detonator
assuring your own and your enemies
Mutual destruction Kaboom then curtains
for both of you the pressing issue and
the reason this secret Summit between
the USSR USA and SCP Foundation was held
was that SCP 1984 was no longer
interested in just waiting for Russia to
be attacked and only reacting after the
fact instead the entity's physical form
was trying to preemptively strike at the
enemies of the motherland attempting to
activate nuclear launches and send
Atomic weapons to destroy the United
States France West Germany and the
People's Republic of China in other
words the Dead Hand was eager to get a
head start at causing total nuclear
Annihilation not to mention potentially
killing millions and reducing Target
countries to little more than irradiated
craters a wash with deadly nuclear
fallout both the Soviet Union and the
United States begged the SCP Foundation
to intervene and contain SCP 1984 and
under the direction of the 05 Council
they stepped in to take direct control
of the situation establishing new
containment procedures in the hopes of
keeping SCP 1984 from hitting as many
launch buttons as it could find the
embalmed remains that seemed to create
the manifestations of the dead-and
entity were held securely in an armed
containment compx Lex near verco yank
part of the Saka Republic within the
Russian Federation SCP 1984 was placed
within a standard humanoid containment
cell which was itself held within a
faraday cage a type of enclosure
constructed with or covered in
conductive material designed to block
electromagnetic fields this was done to
block any external broadcast signals
from reaching SCP
1984 and thus causing it to manifest its
other form if it learned of an impending
attack on Russia even a fictional one
perhaps as a part of a television
broadcast as part of the dead hands
Containment all signals broadcast near
its cage are to be monitored and only
broadcasts featuring doctored
information would reach the entity
thankfully to the work of the SCP
foundation's information control team
SCP 1984 is drip Fred a stream of
carefully fabricated information using
on-site equipment and Facilities a team
of military historians economists actors
and Soviet media Specialists the
information control team have created an
ongoing narrative wherein the Cold War
never ended through falsified radio and
television broadcast made to look like
era appropriated news organizations they
managed to keep SCP 1984 convinced that
the nuclear stalemate between the Soviet
Union and United States is still ongoing
unfortunately sometimes information from
The Real World is able to bleed through
an incident involving SCP 1984 occurred
on August 8th 1984 and almost brought
forth a fullscale nuclear war while
preparing for a campaign speech the 40th
President of the United States Ronald
Reagan uttered the following joke I'm
pleased to tell you today that I've
signed legislation that will Outlaw
Russia forever we begin bombing in 5
minutes naturally thousands of media
Outlets reported on this but signals of
those broadcasts including recordings of
the president's remark made their way to
SCP 1984 Foundation research archers
were both unsure of how these
Transmissions breed the faray cage
surrounding the Dead Hand and were
unable to prevent what happened next
hearing what it could only assume was a
genuine declaration of war the
manifestation of the SCP
19841 entity happened immediately after
Reagan's words reached its containment
cell this time the entity appeared as a
semi-transparent women withered and blue
wearing traditional pashton dress armed
Personnel guarding SC pp1 1984's cage
engaged The Entity causing it to
retaliate lashing out and attacking any
that stood in its way one captain and
two privates that suffered the brunt of
SCP 1984's offensive capabilities began
bleeding heavily from their ears seizing
violently most gruesomely of all a
liquid leaked from their eyes and nose
believed to have been cerebros spinal
fluid while armed Personnel attempted to
use microwave emitting Weaponry to slow
The Entity down the information control
team was Fran IC Ally trying to record a
new falsified broadcast in the hopes
that SCP 1984 would cease its
hostilities and the entity would
dissipate before it was able to travel
at high speed to any nearby Soviet
nuclear facilities and begin bombarding
the United States their first attempt to
record a new broadcast that would result
in a cessation of SCP 1984 Slaughter of
its guards was interrupted when a nearby
wall collapsed desperate to recontain
the creature the information control
team tried to film The podcast a second
time and succeeded although one of the
actors portraying a newsreader suffered
a stroke and had to be edited out to
convince the Dead Hand of its supposed
authenticity What followed was a short
news clip clarifying that Russia's poit
Bureau was in on President Reagan's joke
including old footage of the ussr's
general secretary Constantine chernenko
confirming that the Soviet Union's
nuclear forces were not on high alert
miraculously after 15 more minutes of
sustained fighting with guards SCP
1984's physical manifestation began to
disappear gradually dematerializing
while it seemed to attack with far less
intensity eventually containment was
reestablished at the cost of the deaths
of 17 members of foundation staff both
guards and researchers a further Aid
however suffered traumatic brain
injuries that left them all permanently
disabled the one upside is that this
incident Remains the only time SCP 1984
has ever breached its containment and
caused harm to others and considering
that it could very well have launched
Russia's nuclear Arsenal the casualties
could easily have been much higher so
remember folks don't joke about nuclear
weapons especially if you're the
president you never know what anomalies
lurking in the bodies of dead Russian
soldiers might be listening and if they
are you'd better hope they have a sense
of humor on the 13th of October
1989 the town of Danner Wisconsin was
shaken by a seismic event event unlike
anything they'd ever experienced this
might have been written off as an
earthquake were it not for one
disturbing Factor the ground shaking
event was accompanied by a huge Spike of
radioactivity with the strange
phenomenon happening a month before the
Berlin Wall was torn down during a
period of the Cold War that historians
call the year of Crisis it's easy to
understand why the people of Danner
immediately assumed the worst but the
huge eruption they felt wasn't the
result of a nuclear bomb going on off
the SCP Foundation was alerted to the
event in Danner when they picked up a
series of radio Transmissions coming
from just outside the town when they
arrived they found something incredible
like something out of a sci-fi movie
standing at the Quakes epicenter was a
creature that looked to be from another
world standing 2 m tall and weighing
almost 300 kg the being was green and
brown in color with a bulky humanoid
body its head was a different story
though and res resembled a gigantic
house fly with a prosus and huge
stereoscopic eyes surprisingly the
strange creature did not immediately go
on a rampage instead the being
designated SCP
2273 appeared to be exhausted injured
and extremely malnourished it offered no
resistance at all to the foundation
containment team and it was taken to
site 17 without conflict while the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to visitors
from other worlds there was something
especially unusual about this supposed
alien Invader the doctors who examined
the creature and treated its injuries
found an appendage that seemed to
function as an organic radio transmitter
and large open wounds on its shoulder
blades and forearms where further
appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern the creatures upper
arms and torso were dotted with a
variety of scars and markings that on
closer inspection look looked like
military badges was this some kind of
wounded Intergalactic soldier who had
been stranded on Earth if it was then
how were the organic badges on this
aliens exoskeleton a near perfect match
to military badges worn by soldiers in
the Soviet Union even if they did
reference a unit that didn't officially
exist within the Soviet Army the
scientists were sure this alien wasn't
an alien at all underneath its
exoskeleton was a non-anomalous human
being if that that was true then this
was even more terrifying than an
extraterrestrial visitor the scientists
were sure that the USSR had developed a
new kind of organic armor and this
anomaly showing up in Wisconsin was the
result of a test on us soil that had
gone wrong if that was the case then
there was no telling how many more of
these exoskeletons were out there and
would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly and find
out more while SCP 2273 was recovering
they called in Dr Friedrich an on-site
psychologist who could speak several
languages including Russian Dr Friedrich
would be tasked with interrogating the
SCP on its Origins and the nature of the
suit the interview was conducted via AM
radio from a separate observation
chamber as the biological transmitter
seemed to be SCP 2273 is only method of
communication the interview began with
Dr friederick speaking to SCP 2273 in
Russian only for 2273 to respond that Dr
fried's accent was atrocious and
requesting he used German instead SCP
2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
Major Alexi bellatv initially resisted
being interviewed he believed that he
was a prisoner of war being held by the
American Military according to him he
had been in the middle of battle and
that the Americans had killed his men
and left him for dead in the wilderness
nothing that Dr Friedrich told him that
there was no war or that the foundation
was not a affiliated with the US
government could convince him otherwise
and he refused to talk further before a
second interview was conducted belov was
given an old copy of the level one
researcher General debrief as a way of
helping him further understand the
nature of the foundation and his
containment bellatv was more Cooperative
after that though the realization that
he would most likely be kept in
containment for the rest of his life
caused him great distress and he was
unwilling to speak to Dr friederick for
another 3 days Dr Friedrich didn't give
up though and when batro finally opened
up to the doctor he began to tell him
more and more batro told the doctor that
when he was a child Russia was hit by an
American nuclear warhead and that the
Soviet Union immediately retaliated the
resulting nuclear conflict which batro
called the war to end the world caused
massive Devastation and left most of the
planet dangerously irradiated that is
why he had the exoskeleton it was to
Shield him from the radiation and allow
him to survive above ground
unfortunately batov knew very little
about how the suit was made or how it
worked saying that it was built by the
engineers and that it grew naturally
over a period of several years but
bellatv hadn't made the decision himself
it was his parents who had volunteered
him as a test subject for the
exoskeleton suit program when he was
still young hoping it would give him a
better chance at survival the process of
bonding the exoskeleton to the human
body was extremely painful
but according to batov its advantages
far outweigh the pain the suit not only
helped him survive in a nuclear
Wasteland but made him a better Soldier
the suit allowed him to lift and carry
up to 1200 kg gave him stereoscopic
vision and the organic radio transmitter
allowed him to communicate with other
soldiers across long distances as well
as listen in on encrypted enemy
Transmissions the wounds on his
shoulders and arms where it looked like
appendages had had been ripped out were
where his weapons and Supply packs had
previously been mounted batro had been
stationed with his men in the area he
was discovered when they were attacked
by American soldiers the soldiers had
ripped off bov's weapons and Supply pack
and did the same to all his men as well
they were all shot with batov being
spared for the moment only because the
Americans had identified him as the
commanding officer suddenly there was a
bright flash of light and the American
soldiers vanished not only that that but
the landscape changed where there had
been a post nuclear Wasteland before now
there were lush green trees injured and
disoriented batro began sending distress
signals only to have those signals
intercepted by the SCP Foundation the
most interesting part of bov's story as
far as the foundation was concerned came
during his fourth interview when Dr
Friedrich asked him about the engineers
who had designed the exoskeleton suit in
bov's own words they w't truly known to
man until the years of the Great War and
the revolution the French found them in
buried cities where the Western allies
were digging their trenches eventually
they were made to build weapons for the
war by both sides by his description
these Engineers didn't sound human but
they were by no means unknown to the SCP
Foundation vatro described the engineers
as humanoid nocturnal covered in fur and
possessing technology and intelligence
far beyond that of any human those
familiar with the foundation's history
might already know the engineers by
their Foundation designation of SCP 1000
or their more commonly known name
Bigfoot a quick rundown scp1000 are a
species of intelligent humanoid primates
that lived alongside Humanity in highly
advanced cities until their own
technology was turned against them not
only were their cities wiped off the
face of the Earth but 70% of their
population was slaughtered and the
survivors were driven mad to the point
that their mental faculties were no
higher than those of a chimpanzee or
gorilla the SCP Foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from Human
contact in fear of what the creatures
would be able to do to humanity if they
ever regained their memories and full
mental function and rumors have been
spread about them possessing deadly
anomalous properties but evidently the
destruction of the SCP 1000 species
never occurred in bellat trop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as
complete in that timeline Humanity
regained contact with SCP 1000 after
discovering their underground cities
sometime during World War I after this
discovery both Allied and access powers
began recruiting them to build weapons
and their weapons played a role in both
the Russian Revolution and the second
world war it was because of these
technological advantages that the Cold
War escalated into what would become the
war to end all wars both sides were
armed with not only nuclear warheads but
highly advanced radiation proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue even after the
total Destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life
continued as normal for SCP 1000 in
their underground cities as batro noted
they never wore the armor themselves as
they had no need to venture above ground
only soldiers wear armor and this is not
their War batro continued to adjust to
life in containment and sitting for
regular interviews with Dr R he was
given the rations provided for humanoid
anomalies but in much larger quantities
as the suit required him to eat around
8,000 calories a day to keep it
functioning bellatv also began taking
advantage of his ability to access the
foundation's library he would often read
or listen to classical music
particularly by the Russian composer
chaikovsky he seemed especially fond of
reading The Time Machine by HG Wells no
surprise given he was able to directly
relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with
no way to return home but with little
else to occupy his time batov began to
display symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr
friederick that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought and the lives he had taken in
combat the suit was making the problems
worse too it seemed it was as if he
could never forget as one of its
features was an ability to store and
replay memories this feature was
intended as a strategic Aid that would
allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat this only served to
force batov into reliving his most
painful memories again and again every
night as he tried to sleep he would see
the faces of his men their weapons torn
from their exoskeletons laying in the
dirt after being gunned down by the
enemy like many veterans Bel TR was
being hit all at once with the harsh
realities of War now that his brain
wasn't solely focused on keeping him
alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told Dr
Fredick I trained alongside these men
for years before they put us back on the
surface since we were all young children
we were brothers and I gave them the
order to surrender and got them killed I
should have died with them while the
story of SCP 2273 ends here the story of
Alexi bellatv SCP
22731 continues in 2018 bellatv was
allowed passage to vrad Russia as part
of an anomaly reintegration program
while he was unable to secure employment
within the Russian government as he had
hoped he eventually was taken in by a
monastery and continued to write letters
to Dr friederick until Frederick's
eventual death from lymphoma related
complications there's plenty more on the
monastery the anomaly reintegration
program and and what happened to Major
bellatv when he returned to Russia but
that will have to be a story for another
day welcome back comrade the case of SCP
2273 also known as major Alexi batov has
sparked your imagination and you need to
know more but even if you're not
familiar with the major his story all
you need to know is that it's one of War
tragedy and Alternate Dimensions he
first appeared in the town of Danner
Wisconsin on the 13th of October 19 1989
during an unprecedented seismic event
when he was first discovered the
foundation researchers assumed that he
was an extraterrestrial being on account
of his Advanced organic exoskeleton in a
surprising move for such an imposing
creature batov gave himself up to
Foundation agents without a fight major
batov was then impounded in Foundation
containment site 17 where he was
interrogated thoroughly over a series of
interviews the foundation ascertained
that batro came came from an alternate
timeline where Russia and the US are
locked in a so-called war to end the
world thanks to Advanced military
technology given to them by SCP 1000
bellatv had nearly escaped execution at
the hands of American soldiers and
appeared in our timeline now he is a
prisoner of the advanced suit that
formerly kept him alive but his story
isn't over The Last Remnant of a cold
war turned hot has plenty left to teach
us something that you need to understand
about the SCP Foundation before we go
any further is that it doesn't only
exist in every nation across the globe
it also exists in every Splinter reality
across the Multiverse and these Splinter
realities offer a countless multitude of
tales of different places different
people and different times today's tale
concerns major bellat trv's future in a
universe where the secrecy of the
foundation is broken and the anomalous
world needs to find a way to fit in with
our own
the year was 2018 like many humanoid
anomalies that the foundation was
holding in this timeline bellatv was
released from containment he was no
longer an SCP he was now a mere Person
of Interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean bellatv was
about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
Refugee from a broken alternate World
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the Mana charitable
Foundation this this anomalous charity
has been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to Major bellatv thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project Mana was
able to transport bellatv back to his
home of vrad in Russia there he became
something of a national celebrity making
headlines across the country sitting
down for interviews on every Russian
talk show and even being offered book
deals but as a former military man
bellatv was eager to return to
government life and run for a government
position however this ambition didn't go
very far bellat trov was rejected by all
the government bodies he applied to even
Vladimir Putin wasn't eccentric enough
to want an insectoid cyborg from another
dimension in his cabinet bellatv endured
a rough 2 years in VRA he was treated
more like a sideshow freak than a human
being people didn't want to rent
apartments to him and he was never able
to find permanent employment even
entry-level jobs rejected him nobody
wanted to get food served to them by
what looked to be a 7ot monster and he
seemed equally ill suited to help
Russian women find the right perfume in
department stores in April of 2020 batov
had finally had enough he contacted the
Mana charitable Foundation once again
and asked to be relocated they told him
that some religious institutions in the
area including the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church were accepting and
housing anomalous refugees not long
after this batro truly fell off of the
SCP foundation's radar but one former
Foundation operative was well aware of
major bov's fate it's 2021 Dr Friedrich
the site 17 anomaly psychologist who'
conducted all the initial interviews
with batov all the way back in 1989
started receiving letters from him there
was no indication as to his true
location and they appeared to have been
handled by a man of char Foundation mail
carrier in Russia but Dr friederick was
happy to hear from an old friend
nonetheless due to a career of working
near highly radioactive anomalies like
bellatv Dr Friedrich was suffering from
terminal lymphoma it seemed almost like
an act of Divine Providence that bov's
letters would come to him so close to
the end the two began a correspondence
and it was only after Dr Frederick's
eventual death that the letters came to
the SCP foundation's attention it was
from this final correspondent that the
foundation was able to answer the big
question whatever happened to Major
Alexi batov in his first letter to Dr
friedi batro thanked him profusely he
knew that Dr Friedrich had been a
crucial part of him gaining freedom from
the foundation and credited the
therapeutic techniques taught to him by
Dr friederick with keeping him alive and
sane to this day bellatv expressed a mix
of Amazement at this Brave New World and
a sense of profound weariness as a man
eternally locked into a weapon of War he
felt unsuited to a world in peacetime he
almost missed the scorched irradiated
Russia of his home Dimension but most of
all he missed site 17 he missed Dr
friederick he missed some of his fellow
anomalies like
sc507 the teleporting man and SCP 163
the spacecraft he even missed the
Simplicity of being contained he hoped
that Dr friederick would write back in
his second letter batro began detailing
his experience with the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church despite
growing up in a highly atheistic
communist environment batro became a
amored with the ways of the church he
found them to be highly accepting of him
in spite of his unfortunate
circumstances they displayed a freedom
in their faith that bellatv had never
encountered before and he was eager to
be a part of it with the help of Dr
friederick bellatv was also sending
letters to some of his fellow freed
anomalies he signed off by saying that
he had even started praying something
he'd never considered before the next
letter sent in 2027 struck a much more
somber tone it was sent shortly after
batro discovered Dr Frederick's
diagnosis he wanted to return and see
the doctor one more time but the Mana
charitable Foundation wouldn't allow him
to return to site 17 believing he had
been abused during his time there batro
gave Fredrick his prayers and well
wishes and asked for a number through
which he could contact his ailing old
Friend by the time the next letter
arrived in 2034 bellatv had become a
fully-fledged member of the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church he referred to
the other Monks at the monastery as his
brothers and sisters he seemed to have
finally found a true home there and the
others fondly referred to him by the
nickname Father Anvil but the True Heart
of the letter is bellator's deep concern
for Dr Frederick's Health notably in
this letter he often refers to Dr
friederick by his first name Thomas as
though to emphasize the urgency of the
message after the deaths of several of
the anomalies that batov considered
friends he stated that he couldn't
handle losing anyone else his letter
ends with a poignant passage you may be
unmarried Dr friedi but you are not
unloved you have to be strong for me you
have to be strong for yourself if you're
ever worried that you cannot find the
strength to continue think of the garden
you'll plant this spring I'd like to
share gardening photos with you again
not many of my brothers and sisters here
PR appreciate the simple beauty of a
flower bed or the effort that goes into
growing a patch of vegetables it's a
beauty I'd like to continue to share
trust in the power of Our Lord Thomas
and Trust in the power of modern
medicine God is smiling on you please be
strong with love and prayers Alexi belov
this letter arrived on the 15th of
February 2034 sadly Dr friederick had
already passed away 4 days earlier he
never got to see Alexis's final letter
and it truly was is his final letter
with nobody left for him in the world
major batov stops sending any
correspondence what we know about the
final years of Bell's life all comes
from a few scattered journal entries
translated from Russian after his
passing they provide clues as to the
kind of life he lived during the 29
years the foundation could not account
for his whereabouts and his actions the
first entry written on January 7th 2035
paints a grim picture of batro feeling
broken and isolated in the monastery he
wrote today is the day that our
Monastery celebrates the birth of our
Lord however I feel no desire to
celebrate all of my friends in this
world are dead my brothers and sisters
are partaking in some celebration
outside my dormatory all of their
required ceremonies are complete neither
they nor whatever is happening out there
will lighten my mood belov also wrote
about losing the Comfort he once had in
his faith and his doubts about whether
he would be able to recapture that
comfort but he had survived greater
traumas than this and he would continue
to press on as the months turned to
years and the years turned to decades
batro climbed through the ranks of the
monastery seeing as the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church practically
worshiped the concepts of
industrialization and mechanization the
fact that bellatv was permanently
encased in a biomechanical exoskeleton
probably made him seem even more Pious
to his holy Brethren the final piece of
evidence collected by the foundation
into the The Life and Times of Alexi
batov came just over 20 years later in a
final address written to comfort his
followers in preparation for his own
death bellat recounted the details of
his own life being born into a world of
fire death and mushroom clouds then his
life being suddenly saved by forces
Beyond his control only to place him
into containment for almost 30 years it
was only after accepting the teachings
of the church and accepting the
Clockwork goddess that he felt he was
truly free from his past in this final
note bellatv lay out some of the
teachings of his new religion the belief
in a great mechanized goddess who
planned all of reality according to
batov everything in her design fits
together perfectly like cogs in a
machine turning and twisting in unison
to create an ideal world he hoped to be
forgiven for the many violent sins he
committed in his military life and that
his contributions to this new world were
valuable at the very end of his address
batov wrote I do not believe that my
time in this world is much longer
brothers and sisters when my time of
judgment comes do not mourn me I would
rather you remember these words the
goddess is most pleased with those who
seek kind nonviolent resolution to their
problems because a machine whose gears
grind against each other is a machine
that cannot work see through truth but
also compassion the words are only words
seek out truth within them God bless you
all father Anvil a month after authoring
this statement records indicate that
Alexi belatra was found dead in his room
having passed away peacefully in his
sleep from natural causes he lived A
Warrior's life but died a humble
priest's death the true tragedy in The
Strange Life of major Alexi bellatv is
how little Choice he had in his cir
circumstances but thanks to this tale we
know he did what he could with the life
he was given his remains lay within the
graveyard at the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodoxy Monastery where he spent the
last years of his life with a life as
difficult as his own we can only imagine
he's glad to finally rest you're driving
down a long Highway lost in an area you
don't know too well trying to find the
right turn that'll have you heading back
towards your home you keep driving
the nighttime quiet all around you
deciding to try and break that silence
you reach for the radio turning the dial
to filter through all the garbled
distorted voices and songs from nearby
local radio stations that are too far
out of range to come through clearly you
try your best to listen to the music
from One radio station but eventually
the sound of the static only makes you
wish for the silence you were trying to
break your fingers nudge the tuning dial
on your car radio once again and finally
something comes through it isn't loud or
clear but under the Distortion you can
make out the sound and it isn't a song
or even a late news broadcast the first
thing you hear sounds like a short
musical tone only for about 10 seconds
next a young girl's voice speaking in a
language you don't understand even
through the distorted audio from her
accent you assume it's Russian but you
still have no idea what the word she
saying mean with nothing else to listen
to you let the broadcast play still
driving alone in the dark with nothing
but the strange adolescent voice to
accompany you your mind begins to wander
she sounds like she's speaking something
but the rhythm of the words is somehow
familiar to you even though you don't
speak Russian then it hits you she's
counting but you don't feel smart for
having worked that out instead something
about knowing that makes your blood run
cold you carry on driving through the
night after a few short minutes the
rushan girl stops counting and the
musical tone plays again under the
Distortion leaving you alone in the car
once again with nothing but your
thoughts and questions of what exactly
you just heard thankfully we have the
answer what you heard was SCP 3034 since
1964 this same broadcast has been made a
vast number of times 627 times in fact
you'd have to be within 2 km of the
broadcast point of origin to hear it
where Foundation Personnel have tried
and failed numerous times to triangulate
its source the numbers heard recited in
the SCP 3034 broadcast are actually a
countdown from 200 read aloud in Russian
all Foundation staff are able to do
while stationed at the nearby
provisional site 3034 is scour radio
frequencies for occurrences of SCP 3034
checking their equipment is properly
maintained and calibrated before they
are eventually rotated off site and
replaced with a new group of staff there
is only one rule that any foundation
members working at provisional site 3034
must follow they are only permitted to
send one radio transmission with their
equipment a single phrase in reply to
the SCP 3034 broadcast VI Haru receiving
this the countdown stops and the
broadcast ends but never permanently SCP
3034 has been known to repeatedly occur
seemingly at random the shortest
recorded gap between broadcasts was 2
weeks while the longest so far lasted
six whole months you may have heard the
term number station mentioned before but
these are far from just random numerical
sequences sent out over the airwaves
without purpose General speculation
surrounding number stations points to
them being the tools of Espionage agents
a way of sending Cod coded highly
sensitive messages or information
without the risk of compromising their
cover the use of number station
Transmissions is often attributed to
spies working on foreign soil who
utilize shortwave radio frequencies
speech synthesis Morse code and either
regular or sporadic timing schedules
while it's true that times have changed
and technology has progressed
considerably there appears to be
evidence that number stations are still
used among various intelligence and
Espionage agen es today despite being
considered an old-fashioned method of
communication these lowtech shortwave
stations remain a viable reliable option
for the transmission and reception of
intelligence to field agents the conet
project is a comprehensive Archive of
this phenomenon and its founder Aken
Fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations according to him this
system is completely secure because the
messages can't be tracked the recipient
could be anywhere you just send SP to
the country and get them to buy a radio
they know where to tune and when so what
does the distorted broadcast of numbers
from SCP 3034 mean is it the work of
covert agents and if so whose side are
they on most importantly why does the
SCP Foundation make certain there are
always three of its Personnel on site
ready to send the all aswell message
whenever SCP 3034 begins broadcasting
SCP 3034 was first discovered by the
foundation in
1964 after a Defector from the Soviet
grup a division tasked with acquiring
and studying anomalies on behalf of the
USSR gave them a tip Commander Robert
malfus along with a team of six
including a man named agent Browning
selected for his knowledge of Russian
dialects were sent to investigate at
provisional site 3034 here the team
uncovered partially burned records in
log books all kept in Russian along with
evidence that the site had been
evacuated shortly before their arrival
carved into a desk also in Russian were
two phrases don't let her finish and
tell her all is well on the team's
second day at the site an automated
alarm sounded at 7:30 a.m. alerting them
to the incoming SCP 3034 broadcast
following the instructions on the desk
agent Browning was able to stop the
broadcast telling the young Russian girl
that all was well a tape was partially
recovered by the team from the site and
translated from Russian the GR up
members that had previously inhabited
the station had interrogated one of
their own a man named Sergey whom they
accused of stealing State Property she's
not State Property he replied she has a
name while his grup Superior accused
Sergey of planning to defected the
United States allegedly in exchange for
money and Asylum Sergey denied any
collusion with America he claimed that
the grup at provisional site 3034 were
meddling with powers they could not
possibly hope to understand
his Superior a man named vaslov
dismissed this claiming their work to be
no different to the United States
experimentation with atomic weapons at
the time one does not make deals with
atom bombs Sergey argued one certainly
does not sacrifice little girls to them
shortly after this a struggle broke out
with Sergey having to be restrained
while urging vaslov to cease any and all
interference with it the man spoke of
terrible nightmares that he'd had voices
screaming in the dark Darkness that's
what it wants V that's what it is you
cannot make a deal with his thing we
have finally contained it and now you
want to offer it the tapes audio ends
shortly after this point with no clear
answer as to what Sergey was referring
to or what offer these Russian
operatives had made to it ever since the
discovery of SCP 3034 members of the SCP
Foundation have worked tirelessly to
understand the purpose of these
countdowns as well as determine their
origin by by September 2012 Dr shill was
reaching the end of his tether with the
investigation into the SCP 3034
broadcast over almost half a century the
foundation had made well over 600
recordings of the Russian girls
countdowns but still hadn't determined
any noteworthy information they were
prohibited from contacting the girl via
the same radio frequency only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her
countdowns running out of options schul
kill contacted his colleague Dr
asking for an in-depth vocal analysis of
the various recordings of SCP
3034 even if they could narrow down
where the broadcast was coming from
Maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into understanding SCP 3034
while unable to discover the girl's
location Dr Emerson's analysis did yield
some interesting findings Emerson
learned that these countdowns were not
pre-rec recorded the variations in the
Russian girl's voice her tone her pitch
all seemed to indicate that every
instance of the broadcast was unique
rather than use the same recording this
girl had been counting down over and
over hundreds of times for almost 50
years but there was more schul kill and
Emerson then examined the Distortion The
Sounds interfering with the audio of the
Russian girls countdowns what had
initially seemed like garbled static
seemed to actually be a traditional
voices and much like the girl's voice
these distorted voices were unique
different in every broadcast however
schul kill and Emerson were unable to
accurately determine what these voices
were saying given that the girls
countdowns were always cut short by the
use of the phrase all is well the
doctors did not have long enough samples
of the audio to analyze the other
distorted voices with permission from
the foundation the next five occurrences
of the SCP 3034 broadcast were allowed
to carry on for longer giving the two
doctors enough audio to determine
exactly what the distorted voices were
and the results were extremely troubling
they were screams thousands upon
thousands of children's voices endlessly
screaming both Dr Emerson and Dr schill
agreed that it would be best to continue
responding to SCP 3034 with the correct
phrase and refused to analyze the
distorted screaming audio any further 3
years years later while stationed at
provisional site 3034 a foundation
researcher named Dr Uriel Willis decided
to take matters into her own hands she
conducted an experiment that had not
been sanctioned by the foundation and
attempted to make contact with a Russian
girl giving the countdowns hearing Dr
Willis's voice the girl stopped her
countdown after five long painfully
silent seconds a new broadcast was heard
a piercing high-pitch Screech that
caused extreme pain pain and dizziness
to all the staff working on site unable
to Bear the disorienting sound Dr Willis
told the girl all is well and caused the
noise to stop the following day SCP
researchers noted that there had been a
significant increase in cases of missing
children all around the world a majority
of these disappearances happened at the
same time the Screech had been broadcast
and remain unsolved to this day Dr
Willis faced disciplinary action from
the SCP Foundation and any further
testing of SCP 3034 and attempts to
communicate with the Russian girl were
prohibited only one distinct change has
been noted in the SCP 3034 broadcast
since this incident almost a month later
the countdown was detected in the
correct phrase given but researchers
noted that instead of starting her
countdown from 200 this time the Russian
girl began counting down from
199 nobody knows what will happen if the
Russian girls countdown is allowed to
reach reach zero Personnel working at
provisional site 3034 are told to always
offer her the necessary phrase before
this point in the countdown attempting
to interfere with the broadcast by
contacting this girl directly not only
resulted in intense pain for SCP staff
but also seems to have caused an
unconfirmed number of child
disappearances around the globe as well
as reducing the countdown starting
number from 200 to
199 after a long night on the road you
finally find the right turn sending you
in the right direction as you drive
through the night you keep telling
yourself one thing one small phrase over
and over again you hope the words will
eventually give you comfort but deep
down you start to realize just how
hollow they are that it's just a lie we
tell ourselves so we don't have to face
the inevitable but still what choice do
you have but to keep telling yourself
that all is well SC P 3930 does not
exist thanks for watching now check out
SCP the following information is only
known to seven living people even those
actively guarding this anomaly will
never know this information every single
person who believes they are aware of
the existence of SCP 3930 has the
potential to increase its danger SCP
3930 has been given the risk class
critical the highest possible risk class
for an anomaly meaning that individuals
nearby will invariably be exposed to
acute life-threatening harm and that
these effects cannot be mitigated you
learn about SCP 3930 at your own risk
with the knowledge that this awareness
puts your life at Hazard someday soon
you may be forced to make the ultimate
sacrifice for the good of all life and
matter in the universe that is why it is
imperative that you know one essential
thing SCP 3930 does not exist now with
that out of the way we have only one
question for you can you hear the
screaming it was when Dr vasilev heard
the screaming that he and his ragtag
team of scientists knew it was already
over the year was 1971 and Dr vasilia's
team was stationed at a highly secretive
Soviet research Outpost near what would
later be established as the Russian town
of yusin within the Comey Republic as
far as Dr VV was concerned they were
dead men already well that's not
entirely accurate to be dead is to be
something and the men that had once been
stationed with them but were here no
longer could not be considered something
at all their brush with the immensely
powerful and classified anomaly later
known as SCP 3930 had robbed them of
their very existence now Dr visil of
knew that he and the few remaining men
stationed at the base with him would be
next the s Soviet government had
dispatched a Detachment consisting of
around a 100 soldiers and scientists to
investigate the anomaly in the Comey
Republic as far as they could tell it
appeared to occupy a 1 km square area
within a forest but to say that it
really occupied anything would be a
stretch and out of the over 100 men who
had been dispatched now scarcely 30
remain observation teams had been sent
into the anomalous Zone to collect data
on what exactly they were dealing with
but each time it seemed as though the
researchers were doomed to know less and
less about what they were investigating
from a distance the area didn't even
appear to be anomalous it looks simply
like a continuation of the forest
complete with the expected flora fauna
and even some distant evidence of human
habitation like an abandoned building
but without fail nobody who had ever
seen the building up close had ever
returned thanks to SCP 3930 they had
simply ceased to to be because simply
put when you introduce something into
nothing the nothing wins Dr vasilov had
seen too many good men disappear into
Oblivion and soon it would be his turn
too but first something horrible would
crawl out of the Zone something that
shouldn't exist something that didn't
exist something that will never exist
and yet here it was in science the
observer effect is a dreaded phenomenon
all experiments involve the observation
of phenomenon to collect data and then
prove or disprove a hypothesis but the
observer effect describes the
frustrating scenario where the mere Act
of observing a phenomenon Alters it
reducing the usefulness of the data a
common example of this in mundane life
is checking the pressure of your car or
bike's tires to do this you need to let
out some air thus changing the pressure
but pressure holds a very different
meaning when you're working with with
what might be the universe's largest
patch of nothing because of their prime
directive namely researching the anomaly
doctor vasilev and his fellow scientists
were effectively forced to observe SCP
3930 and 3930 apparently doesn't like
that the scientists only noticed sounds
at first barely perceptible little
screeches that could easily be written
off as your mind playing a trick on you
and in a sense it is but around scp3 930
the tricks played by the Mind become a
lot more practical than anywhere else
what started as sounds soon came to take
on a visual form as more people became
aware of the anomaly and made futile
attempts to observe it from the outside
these scattered Visual and audio forms
soon became nicknamed screamers for
their horrific hateful wailing Dr
vasilia ven team believed that despite
the extremely hostile nature of the
anomalies they had no way of ever
leaving the anomalous Zone that belief
was soon proved wrong and not long after
only 10 researchers remained it seemed
that the last of Dr Vasilio's hope died
with the Lost men but there was some
good news at least with only 10 left to
observe the SCP 3930 anomaly the
screamers began to disappear and the
anomalous Zone became stable once more
10 it seemed was the upper limit of
observers that could distantly engage
with SC P 3930 before all hell broke
loose and then the SCP Foundation
arrived by the time they reached the
long since defunct research Outpost Dr
vasilov was the only one left the final
members of his team had sacrificed
themselves by walking into the void and
joining
non-existence vasil of himself remained
for only one purpose to tell the
foundation what he knew what they needed
to know before bowing out into SCP 39
930 himself along with however many of
the foundation Personnel needed to go to
keep the number of active observers at a
nice clean 10 that is the burden of
knowing and accepting that burden is to
accept that you may one day need to
become unknown in order to protect your
fellow human beings from the horrors
that lay within but what is SCP 3930 and
what are these so-called screamers that
lurk within we have the answers to these
questions the only question for you is
whether you're ready to take on the
grave responsibility of knowing too SCP
3930 does not exist that isn't just a
cover up by the 05 Council it doesn't
not exist in the official capacity it is
quite literally the world's largest
patch of nothingness and anything that
enters it is doomed to become nothing as
well it is a difficult concept to grasp
because fundamentally all language was
built as a tool to communicate unicate
Concepts that on some level exist and
SCP 3930 does not qualify Close Your
Eyes For a Moment seriously do it and
try to imagine nothing what do you see
an infinite space of pure Darkness a
white void stretching on into Infinity
we're sorry to inform you that neither
of these counts as being truly nothing
though Darkness may be the absence of
light to see that Blackness is to still
see something the darkness even implies
the existence of light the same can be
said for the white void for such a thing
to exist we need both the concepts of
the color white and the idea of a void
these are perhaps the lowest bars for
existence imaginable but SCP 3930
doesn't meet them it is well and truly
nothing nothing at all and because it is
nothing its containment procedures are
largely just a matter of information
control if nobody knows about it the
threat threat is contained if ever
someone just happened to wander in they
would stop existing so the problem would
take care of itself as callus says that
sounds on its own the anomaly would
technically be harmless but when mixed
with humans Things become a whole lot
more complicated you see unless you have
The Misfortune to run into SCP 3930 you
will spend your life without ever having
to encounter true nothingness even when
you die the matter that comprises your
body and the energy that comprises your
Consciousness will remain they will just
be transferred into other forms humans
have no reason to ever encounter
nothingness and thus we have no
physiological or psychological equipment
to truly observe and comprehend
nothingness when we're given a true
blank our instinct is to fill it and
that right there is the true danger of
SCP 3930 and the very reason we have to
deal with screamers or as you may know
them pattern screamers that's right if
this whole setup seemed awfully familiar
to you it's because SCP 3930 is the
absolute Global epicenter of pattern
screamers the hateful entities we've
encountered before in anomalies like SCP
0000 nothingness is the natural
environment of pattern screamers but
because SCP 3930 is the only place where
true nothingness exists on our layer of
reality it's also the only place where
pattern screen are able to directly
interact with humans if they become
powerful and defined enough often to
deadly and terrifying results pattern
screamers are an incredibly difficult
concept to wrap your head around
sometimes but allow us to explain close
your eyes again and this time picture a
clown not a specific clown like Ronald
McDonald or Pennywise you have to make
up your own clown let's say he's got
green hair a big blue rubber nose a wide
smile and polka dot clown shoes the
other details are up to you go as simple
or as complicated as you like as long as
it's an entirely new clown you've never
seen in real life now hold the image in
your head really focus on it you can
even use your imagination to make him
dance or walk around fundamentally this
clown does not exist aside from being
the product of chemical and electrical
processes in your brain if this is
indeed an entirely new clown in your
mind it exists only on the level of
thought now imagine if this clown in
your mind was somehow aware of the fact
it wasn't real and that it was only the
product of your imagination imagine that
this clown is infuriated by that fact it
despises you for bringing it into being
doomed to be a concept straddling
existence and non-existence imagine this
clown wants to hurt you it really really
really really wants to hurt you with
every fiber of of its non-existent being
that right there is a pattern screamer
and the frightening thing about SCP 3930
is that if enough people observe it
directly these pattern screamers can
become real they can crawl out of
nothing and then they can show you
exactly how they feel about you bringing
them into existence and when they're
done you'll probably regret ever
existing in the first place think of
them as hostile sentient hallucinations
capable of read reaching maximum power
around SCP 3930 this is because when
humans are given a lack of stimulus
their minds simply create their own this
is why people believe they see the
forest simply continuing into the
anomalous Zone it's the only way the
mind can comprehend what's going on here
it's like the phenomenon of parodia
humans have a natural tendency to see
patterns in things even if they were
never really there it's from these very
patterns that the pattern screamers gain
both their form and their name their
monsters that we create curs to live
hellish half existences and they hate us
for it Dr vasil have described SCP 3930
as a kind of hateful mirror that
reflects back the ugliest shards of our
own minds first broken in the futile
quest to comprehend the true nature of
nothingness thousands have likely been
lost inside SCP 3930 if we can even call
them lost as lost implies that something
is still out there somewhere even if we
never actually find it this cannot be
said for the victims of SCP
3930 they are nowhere and nothing they
can't be found again because there is
nothing to find the foundation has used
declass Personnel to perform Mann Recon
missions into SCP 3930 feeding
information back to the few members of
Mission Control permitted to be aware of
SCP 3930 existence without immediate
termination the DCL classes have
ventured well into the heart of
nothingness even reaching and entering
the building that can be seen in the
distance there they found messes of
Haunting
inconsistencies the place looks like
it's been abandoned for decades but also
has evidence of recent habitation doors
and windows move curtains and hallways
go on forever they feel a sound in their
ears that's similar to the Screech of TV
static no not a screech really more of a
scream it's always in that moment that
the realization hits them they don't
exist not anymore and they haven't for a
little while now they're just a few
scattered memories of the foundation
researcher talking to them reflected
back by SCP 3930 hateful mirror and
moments later they're gone almost like
they were never here at all so if ever
anyone asks you what is s SCP 3930 you
know there's only ever one answer scp3
930 does not exist the war that ended
the world started on October 9th
1971 tensions had been brewing for years
between America and the Soviet Union and
even though people had done their best
to keep a sense of normaly everyone was
wondering when the cold war that had
been brewing for the past 30 years would
boil over there were those who had been
preparing for it for years While others
assumed that it would never amount to
anything neither Nation wanted to to
make the first nuclear strike and even
if that happened the engineers would
come out of their underground cities to
intervene but nobody knew for sure if
the two World superpowers could ever
come to an agreement or if it would all
end in total Destruction October 9th was
the day that question was finally
answered the first American nuclear
warhead detonated over the Gulf of
Finland only a few miles away from the
city of Leningrad where people were
going about their day blissfully unaware
aware of the destruction that was about
to befall them first came a Citywide
blackout as the power grid was bombarded
with a huge surge of radiation that
caused bulbs to blow and wires to glow
like they'd been struck by lightning
there was barely any time to react
before the next wave hit a white hot
flash so bright that many of those who
couldn't get to cover were blinded the
third Wave by far the most destructive
was the force of the explosion itself
like a powerful burning wind it swept
through the city breaking Windows
knocking over street lights ripping the
leaves off trees and bathing every car
building and person with Ash people are
trapped under the debris as some of the
city's older less well-maintained
buildings come crumbling down even
though the Soviet government had been
preparing for this day to come and the
Russian people had been put through
mandatory safety drills no amount of
practice or planning could have prepared
them for the real thing the streets
erupted into chaos cars were crashing
into buildings either because their
drivers had been Blinded By the Light of
the distant explosion or because the
initial wave of radiation had shorted
their batteries people nearly trampled
each other trying to get to underground
shelters as police and military tried to
yell directions over the cacophony among
the crowd a family desperately tried to
stay together Arena and Nikolai batro
held tight to their children Alexi and
Tatiana the whole family was still in
their pajamas and barely had time to get
their shoes on before they started
rushing towards the neighborhood's
designated underground bunker Arena had
Tatiana who was only two clutch tight to
her chest and Nikolai tried his best to
keep 10-year-old Alexis's eyes shielded
as they walked past the dead bodies of
people who were once their friends and
neighbors it will be all right soon son
Nikolai said as much as to try and
convince himself as his son We're Going
Underground just likeing the safety
Thrills Alexi nodded solemnly and kept
his gaze Straight Ahead they were almost
at the end of the street when just above
the sounds of Aid sirens and screaming
people Alexi heard a familiar voice
Alexi Alexi the boy looked down to see
his teacher Mr Petro trapped in the
wreckage of his car he must have been
driving to work when the bomb struck
father stop Alexi yelled tugging at his
father's shirt sleeve that's my teacher
we have to help him or he won't make it
to the shelter the soldiers will help
him once everyone else is in said
Nikolai Alexi didn't listen he wriggled
free of his father's grip and ran to
where his teacher lay pinned under the
wrecked vehicle Nikolai was calling
after him and though Arena wanted to
wait for Alexi to come back she was
swept up in the tide of people and
separated from her husband Mr Petro was
crying thanking Alexi for coming to his
Aid as Alexi got closer he saw there was
blood pooling out from under the wreck
it seemed if Mr Petro were going to make
it out his legs would likely be badly
damaged Alexi tried to lift the car
himself but even though he was strong
for his age he was still only a child a
soldier had been helping people into the
bomb shelter stopped what he was doing
and ran over to Alexi Hey kid the
soldier shouted leave him alone and go
back to your family you're going to hurt
yourself Alexi kicked and struggled
Against The Soldier's grip as he was
dragged back into the line with his
family but he's in trouble Alexi cried
it's not your job to save him his father
scolded as he took his hand and led him
down the stairs where they would reach
join his mother and sister as Alexi and
his father descended into the tunnels
Alexi heard a gunshot from the street
above though he would survive long after
that day he never saw his teacher Mr
Petro again he never asked his father
about what happened the batro family was
reunited in the underground shelter
which had once been an underground train
station Tatiana had started crying and
Nikolai tried desperately to quiet her
Arena hugged her son so tight he felt
she might squeeze s the life out of him
they were packed in with a dozen other
families some they knew and others who
were strangers Alexi recognized some of
the other children from school and saw
that some were there without their
parents while they were in the station a
soldier addressed the group and
explained what would happen next the
train station was to serve as their
temporary shelter until the proper
negotiations were made with the
engineers as for a treaty that had been
written and signed after the second
world war the engineers had agreed to
open the borders of their underground
civilization to humans fleeing from a
crisis above ground once the government
had made a decision the survivors were
to be taken deep underground where they
would live until the war was over above
ground the Soviet Union began dealing
with the Fallout of the initial attack
it was clear that America could no
longer be dealt with reasonably if they
were willing to bomb one of the ussr's
biggest cities though the bombing had
cut Communications between Leningrad and
Moscow eventually contact was
reestablished and the Army was able to
radio the Kremlin with a full report on
the damage Leningrad was in ruin with
over a third of the population dead or
otherwise too wounded to move
underground those who had made it
underground were receiving treatment
from everything from broken bones and
blindness to radiation poisoning in a
word it was chaos Russian Parliament was
quick and ruthless in their decision to
strike back on October 12th secretary
breev authorized nuclear missiles to be
launched at both new New York City and
Washington DC Millions were killed and
just like in Russia the survivors
retreated underground America didn't go
down without a fight though and launched
another missile attack this time at
Moscow it wasn't long before both
countries allies were involved in the
conflict as well with missile strikes
coming from France China North Korea
Germany and the United Kingdom within a
month the surface of the Earth was
dangerously irradiated and any humans
who were still living living had
retreated underground but though the
world had ended the war had not Alexi
batro and his family struggled to adjust
to their new life underground though the
engineers were intelligent and humanlike
their world was so different from the
world Alexi had lived in for the first
10 years of his life he barely ever saw
them the engineers were nocturnal
sleeping while an artificial sun
nourished the genetically engineered
plants that grew around the city but
anytime he tried to as questions about
them he was met with hushed Silence by
the adults the engineers were spoken of
in hushed almost reverent tones they
were the beings that saved Humanity yes
but they had also helped build the
weapons that led to the war in the first
place Alexi barely had any time to
settle into this new life before what
remained of the Russian army started
looking for new recruits reports had
come in from an above ground Scout that
the Americans were working on a new type
of armor that could fully Shield the
wearer against radiation and the Soviets
could not afford to be outmatched when
their army was still recovering from
multiple nuclear attacks but the Army
wasn't asking for able-bodied adult men
to enlist they were looking for children
we can't possibly send our son to war
Arena said arguments at the dinner table
had become common in the batro family he
would not be going to war Nikolai argued
not until their new anti-radiation
technology is perfected he won't be
ready until he's adult how do you know
that what they're making in those labs
won't kill him Arena said do we really
want to trust these underground Devils
with our son how much do we really know
about the engineers anyway they could
have let us all burn on this surface
nickoli said but they didn't I think we
should trust them I want to go said
Alexi I should some of my friends have
already enlisted both of his parents
were stunned but it made sense to Alexi
he wanted the war War to be over and he
wanted to leave the underground city but
most importantly he wanted to know if
anyone was still alive on the surface if
there was even a sliver of chance that
it could be habitable again he wanted to
find out after much discussion ARA and
Nikolai agreed it was what was best for
the future of Russia and ultimately the
future of the human race Alex's parents
delivered him to the office of Army
Recruitment and he was taken by a man
named Commander vov to a specialized
research facility this was when Alexi
met an engineer for the first time the
engineer was tall and hairy like a bear
walking on its back legs but with face
and hands more like a humans it was
overseeing a group of humans and other
Engineers as they tinkered with machines
that Alexi couldn't even begin to guess
the purpose of do not be frightened
Alexi Commander vov said they're going
to explain the procedure to you before
you have to agree to anything the engine
engineer looked the boy over then held
up a jar containing something that
looked like an insect's exoskeleton it
was green the same shade as the ussr's
army uniforms this is our new bioorganic
armor prototype the engineer said we can
only graph it onto you while you are
still growing it must grow with you
starting on your back then moving to
your limbs then your head Alexi was
frightened by theide idea but didn't
want to seem weak he wanted to make sure
his father would be proud of him he was
taken into surgery where the team of
Engineers and human doctors grafted the
plate of bioorganic armor onto his spine
once the surgery was over he was wheeled
into a recovery room where he was fed a
simple meal alongside all of his friends
and classmates they had all gone through
the same procedure over the next 8 years
Alexi and his comrades went through the
painful process of growing their
exoskeleton like the engineer had said
it grew with them but the growth
happened in painful spurts rather than
gradually the worst thing about the
armor was that it couldn't be removed
but it gave them many advantages to
normal soldiers as well once it covered
Alexis's legs he found he could jump
higher and run farther than any human
normally could when it grew over his
arms it gave him increased strength by
the time he was 18 it had covered his
head giving it a fly-like appearance but
also granting him stereoscopic vision
and the ability to hear radio
Transmissions without the need for any
other communication device during this
time he and the other boys were trained
by Commander vov learning how to use the
powers granted to them by their
exoskeletons for combat when they were
deemed ready they were all outfitted
with shoulder cannons Supply packs and
guns all of which were also bioorganic
and were surgically attached it had been
eight long years since the end of the
world and Alexi was now able to set foot
back on the surface the world he
returned to was almost unrecognizable
there were no signs of life outside of
weeds and Vines overtaking the
irradiated ruins of buildings within the
first hour of returning to the surface
Alexi gave up any hope of finding
survivors he heard volkov's voice
barking orders through the suit there
was no time to reminisce about the past
the soldiers had a job to do in 19 14 an
arch Duke of Austria Hungary was shot by
a Serbian nationalist this led after a
series of Nations signing treaties with
other nations to one of the bloodiest
conflicts ever fought a war that was
unlike any that had been fought at the
time trench combat mud and sandbags
newer deadlier advancements in the art
of warfare vile incurable and fatal
diseases and months upon months of
Misery all while trapped in dark dank
dugouts the Great War the first world
war it's gone by many names since its
ceasefire in 1918 and while there aren't
many left of the generation that
remembers it there are still plenty of
scars left on the world that remind us
of the horrors but there's one that
seems to be keeping those wounds fresh
reminding us that war is indeed hell as
that rough Beast slouches towards its
destination this is SCP
2574 what appears from the outset to be
nothing more than a stone sculpture of a
lion comprised of sandstone and living
tissue standing at around 12 M tall SCP
2574 is much more than a mere statue in
fact it is a living creature after all
this is the SCP Foundation we're talking
about here where inanimate objects are
rarely inanimate at all or will at least
possess some form of anomalous
properties setting apart anything
ordinary and thus drawing the interest
of the foundation SCP 2574 is similar in
that regard and not just for being a
living statue creature for one the
anomaly is capable of movement albeit at
a gradual rate that only progresses
between 3 in 5 km per day attempts by
the foundation to slow or halt the
movement of SCP 2574 have been so far
unsuccessful as it seems that any
obstacle placed in its path are unable
to deter it this includes both man-made
and naturally occurring obstructions
meaning there is little that can be
deployed to keep SCP
2574 physically contained even if a body
of water is in its path The Entity can
swim at a rate of between 2 and 3 km per
day and will normally either crush or
climb over any obstacle on land at the
previous annual budgeting meeting the
top mins of the foundation's accounting
department revealed to an INF f805
Council that SCP 2574 had been
responsible for an estimated total of
25.3 million Us in Damages since its
Discovery the second most pressing
matter raised during that presentation
was that $12 deaths and a further 625
injuries the anomaly had also caused
despite pleas from the Ethics Committee
the foundation accountants were still
adamant that the cost of Damages was
more significant now a number of
prevailing questions might be plaguing
you regarding SCP
2574 for one what does this creature
want if it has freedom of movement and
can't be physically obstructed by the
foundation then is it just aimlessly
wandering free and causing want on
destruction or does it have a specific
want or goal it seeks to attain and for
another what does an almost 40ft tall
lion have to do with World War I well it
might surprise you to know that SCP 257
4 has everything to do with the Great
War literally everything and as for a
goal it has one or rather it has a
specific destination it seems to be
gradually heading towards and if it
makes it all the way there it could
spell disaster for the entire globe in
fact it could plunge us back into one of
the most devastating conflicts the world
has ever seen can you guess which one
SCP 2574 possesses a wide array of
latent anomalous effects
Beyond its General functionality and
movement above the Sandstone line
creature it is constantly surrounded by
A Flock of around 6,000 Birds of Prey
any that find themselves flying into the
path of SCP 2574 are assimilated into
the growing flock designated as SCP
25741 the mass of birds is fixated on
attacking s SCP
2574 swooping low to strike at its
smooth muscle tissue with using their
Peaks and Talons this however seems to
do little to deter SCP 2574 from making
progress as the anomaly constantly
regenerates from physical damage it
incurs from SCP
25741 perhaps the most notable and
noticeable of SCP 2574 anomalous
properties is the effect it has on its
surroundings as it progresses towards
its destination the area around SCP 2574
will undergo a physical trans formation
in response to the presence of the lion
this transformation results in the
nearby region temporarily becoming a
World War One era combat zone the ground
below becomes riddled with trenches
carved through the Earth thick muddy
bogs and coiled razor sharp Nets of
barbed wire litter the area the change
triggered by SCP 2574 is hardly just a
cosmetic one either the foundation have
observed a number of First World War
related manifestations that occur in the
the wake of SCP
2574 man-made land masses like trenches
and dugouts will appear nearby the front
lines reappearing after more than a
century Weaponry from the area is also
present following the arrival of SCP
2574 and this isn't just limited to
Firearms World War I was one of the
earliest large-scale conflicts in
history where in both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of
biplanes as well as chemical warfare as
a result signs of these can also be
found whenever SCP 2574 is nearby but
again the transformation as CP 2574
brings about is not just limited to
recreating battlefields what some of you
may not know is the Great War did not so
much revolve around a core idealistic
difference between both sides as its
successor did instead the first world
war was a geopolitical grudge match
between large Global superpowers
attempting to make grandio displays of
their amassed military strength the
assassination of arch duuk France
Ferdinand of Austria at the hands of a
Serbian extremist group was the Catalyst
that set off a chain reaction of events
that ultimately led to War as a result
of this SCP 2574 is anomalous influence
also extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters a country
that the Sandstone leonine entity enters
will suffer a rapid change in its local
populations mentality the ordinary
people living there will start to
experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government while the
ruling powers of said country will
increase its use of force against its
own civilians this effect is more
noticeably potent when SCP 2574
interacts with countries that were
directly involved in the first world war
increasing levels of civil unrest and
discontentment among the population
these are often countered with
worryingly increased levels of police
brutality along with governments
enacting aggressive foreign policies and
sometimes antagonizing other countries
as if they are eager to fight these
effects don't necessarily worsen the
closer SCP 2574 gets to a particular
country but do seem to increase the more
it approaches its predicted destination
and where is that you may ask the
foundation have calculated that based on
SCP 2574 trajectory since its emergence
back in 2012 The Entity is headed for
the city of Saro the capital city of
Bosnia and Herzegovina what possible
reason could SCP 2574 have for wanting
to venture towards this specific Bosnian
City well one cursory glance at the
history of Saro will give you the answer
it's where the assassination of arch
Duke France Ferdinand took place the
event commonly attributed with starting
the first world war the transformative
effect SC SCP 2574 has on its
surroundings began when the leonine
Leviathan first appeared and commenced
its journey toward Saro on December 24th
2012 since then the SCP Foundation has
been closely monitoring the Sandstone
creatures movements and attempting to
log all of the anomalous effects it has
had over the course of making its way
closer to the site of France ferdinand's
assassination over 5,000 km away to the
East of K extends Capital aana SCP 2574
caused an unusual World War I anomalous
effect any written works published in
either Russian or kazak began to
randomly feature passages from Irish
poet WB Yates these extracts from his
body of work range from single sentences
to entire poems being featured in other
writer Publications regardless of author
or genre Yates for anyone unfamiliar was
widely considered one of the greatest
poets of the 20th century however unlike
the authors of numerous poems and songs
to come out of the first world war WB
Yates was never directly involved in the
conflict itself and didn't write much
about it barring a few notable
exceptions but more on him in a moment
when SCP 2574 approached Russia things
started to escalate clouds of deadly
chlorine gas an early World War I
chemical weapon began forming in rural
areas throughout Europe that couldn't be
dispersed for days at a time as soon as
the Towering anomaly got close enough
Russian military forces began launching
a series of drone strikes and aerial
bombardments targeting SCP
2574 when these attacks failed tensions
mounted with bordering countries the
situation only getting worse when it was
discovered through an intelligence leak
that Russia was planning a nuclear
strike against the creature a move that
likely could have spelled disaster for
the neighboring countes
SCP 2574 of course sustained no damage
and continued on its course given that
they couldn't physically contain SCP
2574 the foundation was forced to think
outside of the box when it came to
coming up with some kind of solution
there were already too many eyewitnesses
aware of the leonine leviathan's
existence to consider administering
amnestics even on a large scale the fact
was too many people already knew about
SCP 2574 and would make such a move
pointless the best that the foundation
could do to combat if not counteract the
effects of SCP
2574 was to work directly with
governments affected by the creatures
World War I transformative effects to
try and repair the damage left in the
anomaly's wake and eased the tension and
violence it caused it became the
foundation's job to deter any country
planning an armed military response to
the presence of SCP
2574 as any such strike would endanger
both their military and civilian
populations while causing no damage to
the anomally in the interest of trying
to solve the problems posed by SCP 2574
reverting parts of Europe to hellish
First World War era battlefields the
foundation made a rare agreement to
collaborate with another large
organization specializing in the
anomalus the global occult Coalition
working directly with the GOC their goal
was to create a large-scale mimetic
countermeasure that would effectively
reset the toll SCP 2574 had exacted on
global Psychology by altering people's
temperaments and creating mass political
unrest as it progressed towards the
Bosnian Capital however given the tense
history between the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition their
attempts at creating a mimetic
countermeasure are still ongoing since
neither group wants the other to engage
them in fullscale mimic Warfare as such
the proposed countermeasure will consist
of two parts with neither organization
being able to replicate the other's half
meanwhile SCP 2574 progress across
Europe was responsible for a number of
other significant changes physically
socially and politically recreating the
conditions of the first world war
poppies a flower that has since become
synonymous with the remembrance of the
conflict began to grow in regions within
Russia where they wouldn't natur occur
this included within Urban locations the
red flowers sprouting in and around
buildings as a result of such a
high-profile anomaly causing such
widespread unrest to spread a number of
religious cults centered around SCP 2574
began to form while the living
descendants of World War I veterans
began suffering from Vivid
hallucinations that depicted their
ancestors firsthand experience of the
fighting these Colts began to amass more
and more of those effect Ed by SCP
2574 the SCP Foundation was able to
observe some of the sermons delivered by
these religious cults who appeared to
view the public appearances of SCP
2574 as signs of an impending apocalypse
come to us and embrace your salvation
one cult leader exclaimed in a sermon
discover the words of the Prophet Yates
who spoke this sacred truth that all of
history is a spiral and that we have
spiraled outwards towards chaos learn
the true nature of the second coming it
appeared that some of these Cults viewed
the Poetry of WB Yates as prophetic in
regards to SCP
2574 they would often reference the
second coming which interestingly was
the name of one of his poems written in
the aftermath of World War I yates's the
second coming refers to a rough Beast
slouching towards Bethlehem the SCP
Foundation found a has since uncovered
some erratic writings made by the poet
before his death that allude to
Bethlehem despite no record existing of
him ever traveling there it is believed
that Yates somehow figured out what SCP
2574 was and that The Closer it gets to
its destination the mo civilization will
spiral further out of control towards
total allc consuming chaos further
research by the foundation also
uncovered a testimony made by gabilo
princip the Serbian man responsible for
assassinating Arch duuk France Ferdinand
of Austria and thus sparking the first
world war princip seems to have had had
some knowledge about SCP
2574 and apparently killed the arch
dukee as a way to begin the creatures
journey in order to make Society more
chaotic with SCP 2574 progressing
worryingly closer to the S side of
France ferdinand's assassination further
chaos rapidly began to spread anarchic
sentiments took hold of of most of
Europe leading to an increased rate of
violent encounters between civilians and
police in many countries including
Ireland France Great Britain and Italy
with a number of these experiencing
widespread rioting in their major
population centers any government or
political party compelled by SCP 2574 to
openly expe the same Anarchist
sentiments were soon seeing a rapid
increase in their public approval
gaining more popularity in polls than
the their opposition as a result of
these heightened tensions between the
public and the government of their
countries assassination attempts of
polititions saw an alarming increase of
around
60% SCP 2574 caused countries that had
existing hostile relations to engage in
armed skirmishes at their borders with
at least one of these battles occurring
every 2 weeks and each time threatening
to spark a much larger scale conflict
thanks to the anomaly's effects the
international tensions dissolving
alliances between countries and Adoption
of nationalism which were all factors
leading to the start of the Great War
were beginning to rapidly spread once
again by the time SCP 2574 was around
550 km from Saro people began
experiencing injuries common among
soldiers during World War I many
patients would die during surgery only
for their bodies to disappear shortly
afterwards conflict erupt between
Ireland and England and as SCP 2574
entered Bosnia and Herzegovina many
began to report suffering intense dreams
about the anomaly a number of these
reports seem to state that SCP 2574 was
attempting to communicate with them and
multiple websites began logging the
Sandstone Lion's appearance in their
dreams and things will only get worse
the closer SCP 2574 gets to Saro SCP
2574 contains the raw energy of World
War I one of the most catastrophic
events in human history a global
conflict with a death toll in the tens
of millions the SCP Foundation estimates
it'll reach the site of France
ferdinand's assassination within a month
and from that point given the effect
it's had on the rest of Europe there's
only one likely outcome when that rough
Beast slouches towards its ultimate
destination War your new SCP Foundation
researcher on tour of sight 17
familiarizing yourself with the location
and its many anomalous inhabitants it's
the second largest Foundation
containment sites out there and it's
also the kind of job that most Junior
researchers dream of lowrisk humanoid
containment baby most of the inhabitants
in your sector are cordial willing to
comply with orders from staff and seem
for all intents and purposes pretty much
human you pass from door to door looking
through the viewing hatch of each one
you can't believe what you're seeing
It's a Wonderful who's who of anomalous
humanoids you see the wise bearded face
of SCP 343 known to some as God you see
the blue eyes and Shining blonde hair of
Iris SC cp105 looking wistfully into a
Polaroid picture you see the tanned
melancholic face of Cain SCP 073 as he
stares off into the middle distance face
after face after face passes you can see
yourself getting more familiar with each
one yes your time here will be wait was
that Hitler you stop and walk back to
the door you just passed where you can't
help but stop and stare in disbelief yes
it's him it's got to be him you
recognize the unpleasant sneer the
Hideous combover the silly little
toothbrush mustach the SCP Foundation
seems to have Adolf Hitler the former
leader of the Third Reich in World War
II in active containment and his
designation is SCP 2430 you've seen
Killer toasters and and masks that can
take over people's minds but you've
never seen anything as surreal as this
you immediately run to your Superior and
ask how and why Hitler is in one of the
sight 17 humanoid containment cells
Buckle in because we can guarantee it's
one of the most insane stories you've
ever heard it's late April 1945 and the
Soviets are rampaging through Nazi
Germany destroying everything in their
path the German forces have been nearly
obliterated and Hitler and the rest of
his Reich chancellory have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath Berlin there on
April 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday Hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the Soviets as they
wished to have had the chance to kill
him themselves 2 Days Later Soviet
forces stormed the fur bunker it was
little more than a formality at that
point as the news of Hitler's death had
already gone public by the time they
arrived all that was left of Hitler was
a pile of mostly burned remains A
fitting end for someone who had caused
the same cruel fate for so many others
they collected what was left of Hitler's
body and brought it back to the
Fatherland a kind of trophy for their
Nation but Hitler dying before Joseph
Stalin could get his hands on him was
not what Stalin wanted Hitler had not
only caused the deaths of millions of
Russians he had personally betrayed
Stalin's trust and when you betray
Stalin bad things happen to you very
very bad things 2 years earlier in 1943
Soviet forces had raided a camp in jisa
belonging to the obscura corpse think of
them as the Nazis own version of the SCP
Foundation who were hellbent on
Gathering anomalous people and artifacts
to increase the power of the Third Reich
they were a far more militant offshoot
of the T Society a group that described
itself as a study group for Germanic
Antiquity while this may seem innocent
that tuo Society was actually a racist
cult closely aligned with the goals and
ideas of the German Nazi party many have
also speculated that they were heavily
involved in the occult and it's this
mysticism obsessed offshoot that went on
to form the obscura corpse and in their
janosa base they had obtained a hundred
pieces of Enchanted occult flesh with
human skeletons embedded in each of them
this flesh was believed to originate
from the mythological simir the Beast
hunted and eaten again and Again by the
pantheon of Norse gods having the
qualities of both a wild boar and a goat
the flesh can bond to skeletons and give
them a quality somewhat like immortality
any flesh cut from them will regrow time
and time again if given a rest period
now that he had both the Flesh of serir
and Hitler's burnt remains Stalin had an
idea a perfect way to not only bring
satisfaction to the Russian people and
the world but to finally exact the true
Revenge that Hitler had denied to him he
called it project judica namely after
the very bottom level of Hell reserved
for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he
couldn't kill Hitler before but if
Stalin was going to get the chance
Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists try to use
Arcane methods to resurrect Hitler by
combining his remains with the Flesh of
surir at times they even came close to
creating a new Hitler but there was one
huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for Stalin's
plans of violent and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his Twisted dream a
reality Stalin formed an Unholy alliance
with a group known as the uralic flesh
Crafters a neoc ciric cult that was a
branch of the nightmarish religion
religion of sarcasm this group
essentially worships avatars of Flesh
corruption and disease and are behind
some of the most terrifying and
disgusting anomalies out there including
the flesh that hates and the bone
Orchard true sarcus ists who show the
proper Devotion to their vile deities
and know the right rituals to contact
them are often granted anomalous powers
that spread the saric influence further
across the known Dimensions these Powers
will usually involv having a
supernatural ability to to manipulate
the Flesh of themselves and others
allowing them to enhance their bodies
cheat death and warp their enemies
Beyond repair they can sometimes even
create life if they're a powerful enough
acolyte of sarcasm and it was because of
these powers that Stalin wanted the
eroic flesh Crafters under his command
in exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
Flesh of surir which they could use for
their own Sinister saric purposes a deal
was struck and the true work of
resurrecting Hitler began Stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the Eric flesh Crafters extra bones
to compensate for what had gone missing
from Hitler's burnt remains he also gave
them samples of the Flesh of camir to
achieve the desired effects of a near
Immortal tolerance for damage however
Stalin demanded that he heighten this
new Hitler's capacity to experience pain
so that every suffering inflicted on him
would be three times worse than anyone
else and true to their word the flesh
Crafters got to work and began creating
just such a creature by now it was the
early 1950s and Stalin was putting the
pieces in place for his Grand Revenge
once the new Hitler was finished he
would hold a new trial for him in the
Russian courts where he would preside
over the sentencing personally once the
new Hitler was done the Eric flesh
Crafters were rewarded for their
participation in project judica with
4,000 kg of the Flesh of surir Stalin
now had his very own personal Hitler
chew toy that he could maim and torture
as much as he pleased knowing that he
would always heal and soon be ready for
more in their infinite generosity the
flesh Crafters even taught Stalin a new
method of Torment for his old enemy a
process known as the right of Neos it's
a torture that's been described by many
as being like the Chinese lingi also
known as the lingering death or slow
slicing but it is probably best known as
the death by a Thousand Cuts the Soviets
and the saric parted ways for the next
few years Stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting Hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until Stalin
himself eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the Soviet answer to the
SCP Foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal Hitler
clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never Escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile Nazis
who'd escaped the war the new Hitler was
Spirited Away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in Argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
Hitler back up they have managed to
rescue Zira and bring him to safety but
he is effectively dead on the inside I
blame the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of the fura who may have been
Beed by the Reds vava I wish we could
mercy kill him but we've tried
everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain
sight they didn't have the new Hitler
for long though in 1960 efforts to hunt
down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler
was soon captured by mad agents
searching for Nazis in Buenos arees and
then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that
he had a number of anomalous properties
such as his incredible regenerative
abilities as well as the fact that his
DNA seems to be based on that of a wild
boar and a goat rather than a human
however x-rays conducted by the
foundation have discovered traces of
cyanide still in his system as well as
traces of lead in his skull where the
bone has regrown over the B it in other
words it was unquestionably the real
Hitler and he was now in Foundation
custody forever more it's such a wild
story even by Foundation standards that
you can barely summon the words to
respond once your supervisor is finished
he just stands there with a slight smile
basking in your amazement before you can
even ask again he confirms the facts one
more time yes it is the real Hitler the
only functional difference is that he
can't die and he has a heightened sense
of pain compared to most people people
you think on what you've been told for
just a moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do there is something
inherently unnerving about the sight of
someone wearing a gas mask maybe it's
the wide soulless Port holes where a
person's eyes should be or the huge
round filter extruding from their face
that makes them look like something
inhuman it could also be the fact that
if ever you see someone wearing a gun
gas mask you may be surrounded by
poisonous gas and if you're not wearing
one yourself someone else's gas mask may
be the last thing you ever see whatever
the reason you might be wondering why
we're talking so much about gas masks
well that's because you're about to meet
SCP
1499 which is as you might have already
guessed an anomalous gas mask for all
you military history Buffs out there SCP
1499 is specifically a Soviet gp5 gas
mask these were produced between 1962
and 1990 as a way to protect the wearer
from The Fallout of a nuclear blast back
then during the Cold War an atomic
conflict between the United States and
the USSR that's Russia was a constant
threat and so these masks were sent to
most of the Fallout shelters in the
Soviet Union while the gp5 masks could
survive in all weather and protect
against radioactive substances for a
Time
some of their filters contained a number
of harmful chemicals like lead and
asbestos the fact that these gas masks
were airtight would mean that somebody
could end up inhaling these toxic
chemicals while trying to protect
themselves from nuclear fallout if you
look up the definition of irony in the
dictionary you may see a picture of one
of these gas masks sitting right next to
it and if you think that sounds bad just
wait until you hear what sets SCP 1499
apart from the rest upon first
inspection The Mask still seems to
perform its original function the filter
works properly and the airtight seal is
still formed when placed upon somebody's
head however when warned by someone the
anomalous effects of SCP 14499 will also
activate while it doesn't fuse to the
wearer's face and turns them into a
hysterical zombie chillingly asking for
their mommy the gas mask does cause
Anyone who puts it on to completely
disappear from view now it's worth
noting that this isn't a gas mask that
grants its user the power of
invisibility if that was the case this
anomalous item may actually be desirable
scp-1499 instead causes a person to
physically vanish as in they are no
longer detectable at all subjects that
have worn SCP 1499 report that they
don't feel any sensation of moving they
simply put the mask on and end up well
we'll get to where it is they go you see
through testing the SCP Foundation
researchers were able to determine that
giving someone a two-way radio before
they put SCP 1499 on means that they can
still be contacted after they vanish and
it's through these radios that the
foundation discovered where the mask
wearers go during testing subjects have
reportedly found themselves in a strange
alternate Dimension after putting on SCP
1499 it has been described as a dark
environment inhospitable Barren and
filled with tall black tower-like
structures you would think being
unceremoniously transported to another
dimension by a gas mask would be bad
enough just wait until you meet the
locals according to a number of test
subjects a group of humanoid entities
inhabit this Dimension designated as SCP
1499-1 these creatures are taller than
the average person completely Ned and
covered from head to toe in a coat of a
dark viscous substance unlike anything
found in our dimension these scp4 1499-1
entities also have been described as
having too many mouths and a large
number of eyes covering their bodies
from the sound of it the whole place
makes the upside down from stranger
things sound like a pleasant destination
for a family vacation for the record the
reason we say according to a number of
test subjects is that there has never
been any photographic or video evidence
of this place and the creatures that
inhabit it all that we have gathered to
date has comes strictly from firsthand
descriptions of those experiencing the
anomalous effects of SCP
14499 luckily anyone that puts on SCP
1499 and finds themselves in this place
has a very quick and easy Escape rounde
should a subject encounter any danger in
this dark inhospitable dimension then
taking the gas mask off will drop them
right back into our own plane of
existence upon arriving back they will
not have moved from the spot they were
standing in when they first disappeared
appeared but it is unknown exactly how
the gas mask is able to return them or
indeed how it can send someone to an
entirely different dimension at all so a
gateway to another dimension that's what
the mask is the foundation has been
running tests on SCP 1499 since they
first acquired it at first using d-class
Personnel the first test involving SCP
14499 saw a d class d67 393 told to put
on the mask when she did she found found
herself transported inside a building
that was constructed from an unknown
black substance d67 393 surveyed the
room she was in for a few seconds only
to hear something moving close by the
sound caused her to panic and she
wretched the gas mask off her face
returning to the test chamber given that
there was now a risk of losing a SCP
1499 the foundation moved forward with
tests involving trained agents instead
of d-class personnel following this the
next test involved in agent C putting on
the mask and like the d-class before him
he found himself in the same dark room
but instead of taking off as SCP 1499 at
the first sign of trouble this agent
explored his surroundings agen C was
able to descend the building to a
reasonable degree until he heard sounds
coming from the floor below after hiding
himself agenc C witnessed the very first
sighting of the SCP 1499-1 creatures
remaining undetected and then SA safely
removing the mask when the creatures had
passed another agent known as agent U
was selected for an SCP 14499 test
chosen especially for her extensive
training in stealth like those before
her she put on the gas mask instantly
she found herself in the place where her
predecessor had left off and continued
the exploration of the building
detecting movement from the floors above
agent U exited the building and spotted
a number of SCP 1499-1 one instances the
creatures were mulling aimlessly around
each sporting their own unique mutations
occasionally uttering low grading Noises
by now if they were still using DCL
classes they probably would have lost
the mask and the people wearing it a 100
times over never get a d-class to do a
field agent's job making her way past
more of the tall dark structures the
agent followed and observed a group of
four creatures a fifth approached them
prompting one from the group to step
forward as agent you watched these SCP
1499-1 creatures began violently
assaulting each other until she2 pulled
the gas mask off and returned to the
foundation shortly afterward one final
agent Agent K was sent into this
alternate Dimension this was less of a
test more a mission with the purposes of
reconnaissance to give the foundation a
better clearer idea of what the
environment was like and to possibly
even make contact with the the SCP
1499-1 and understand them better
however the outcome that followed could
not have been worse Agent K appeared in
the other dimension between two of the
black structures the lighting made it
difficult to see much of the environment
around him but he remarked that the
buildings resembled tall spires
constructed out of hard rock as was the
ground beneath him after a few short
minutes he soon spotted a group of SCP
1499-1 entering a larger structure an
elaborate build building with a number
of towers and spikes on it as well as
what appeared to be blood approaching
the building with caution Agent K
located a small secluded side entrance
away from the larger front door as
quietly as he could he made his way
inside the sounds of grinding filled the
air from all around him as Agent K saw a
huge group of the mutated humanoid
creatures each one had their mouth wide
open all of their mouths wide open
making a cord of grading sounds the
entities were according to case
description all facing towards one of
the SCP 1499-1 that was standing on a
platform in front of them with a number
of bodies around it this creature seemed
to be leading an odd ritual and began to
cut open its own torso wormlike
creatures Spilled Out of the open womb
and a beam of light followed projecting
out of the entity's chest Agent K
realized that this light was some form
of portal another worm like the kind
that had come out of the ritual Leader's
chest began to appear in the portal
deciding to act Agent K dashed out from
his hiding place opening fire at the
creatures all around him he reached for
something glowing in the lead entity's
chest which he thought was bringing the
worm creature through the portal
grabbing it Agent K pulled off the gas
mask and found himself back at the
foundation holding a human heart but it
doesn't end there at the exact same time
on the exact same date a man attacked
the Cathedral of Christ the savior in
Moscow Russia during the church's
morning Services the gunman entered
dressed in a suit with a gas mask over
his face and proceeded to shoot 10
civilians six were killed three left in
critical condition including the
church's chanter however the worst
occurred to the priest performing the
service the attacker ran to the front of
the cathedral producing a knife which he
used to cut open the priest's chest and
remove his heart then just as quickly as
he had appeared the asent vanish before
the eyes of multiple Witnesses and
Moscow police were unable to find any
trace of the man officially the
cathedral was attacked by Nikolai orov
undercover Foundation operatives inside
Russia's media and military have spread
this cover story of a violent man who
acted alone in his attack on the church
meanwhile the SCP Foundation is keeping
Agent K detained questioning him about
his involvement in the incident
according to him everything happened
exactly as he described it no church no
priest just him wearing SCP 1499 and
surrounded by the creatures the audio
recordings taken from his exploration
Mission also seemed to align with this
story but that still doesn't explain how
another figure in a gas mask appeared in
Moscow and claimed the lives of multiple
churchgoers not only that but
dispatching them in the exact same way
Agent K dealt with the SCP 1499-1
creatures the only possible explanation
was that agent K was the perpetrator
even if in his mind he was still telling
the truth hoping to avoid another
incident the 05 ccil has suspended all
further testing with SCP 1499 Agent K
has been scheduled to undergo a
psychological evaluation believing the
creature he saw being summoned had to be
stopped at all costs the other agents
and the d-class involved in earlier
testing are all being brought in for
questioning as well it is still unknown
what the anomalous effect of scp4 99
truly is is it actually capable of
transporting someone to another
dimension or does it give a person
hallucinations that make them think
they're gallivanting off in dimension X
while they're actually walking up to a
church about to do something Unthinkable
with testing suspended we may never know
but it leaves us with an important
message think carefully about everything
you do because what you think you can
see doesn't always reflect what's really
there a mobile task force makes its way
through the Siberian Forest snow covers
the trees the only light comes from the
moon shining through the branches the
commander holds up a hand signaling the
team to halt in a small clearing in
front of them is the creature they've
been searching for it appears to be part
deer part human the creature howls in
pain as it rips the skin from its body
the SCP agents watch it in horror as the
creature reaches its arm high into the
air and plunges es a knife into its
stomach it doubles over in pain and
stops screaming the creature pulls the
knife from its midsection and stands
upright blood splatters across the
shimmering white snow it turns towards
the mobile task force and slowly walks
towards them help me the creature
Whispers I need you to save me from
what's inside it collapses to the ground
the mobile task force secures the
creature in a containment vehicle in
preparation for further examin ation
this is SCP 1068 Ru shell of God when
they arrive with the creature to an
undisclosed SCP Foundation site location
Dr belov is put in charge of learning
more about the entity when SCP 1068
first awakens in its containment chamber
belov is watching from behind a two-way
mirror the creature walks up to the
mirror and examines the countless scars
and stitches that cover its body SCP
1068 shakes its head and gingerly runs a
long finger along the freshed wound
where it stabbed itself earlier it
glances around the room as if looking
for something then turns back towards
the two-way glass what time is it it
asks Its Reflection Dr belov knows that
the creature is talking to him it may
not know who is watching him but it
knows there is someone there Dr belov
pauses for a moment what harm can it do
to tell the time he thinks belov pushes
the intercom button and speaks you've
been in there for almost 6 hours he says
into the microphone SCP 1068 looks
startled its eyes open wide as it scans
the room again you need to let me out of
here it shouts quickly or you will all
be in danger the creature starts to bang
on the glass causing Dr belov to take a
few steps back there is fear in its eyes
that terrifies the doctor belov
tentatively walks back towards the
intercom button and pushes it I'm not
sure it'd be safe to let you out quite
yet my friend why don't you tell me
what's going on there is no time SCP
1068 screams I I can feel him coming
just as it finishes the sentence SCP
1068 stumbles backward Dr bov looks on
in horror as the creature's stomach
begins to expand as if something is
pushing on it from the inside a set of
claws rips through its skin from within
warning lights begin to flash in the
observation room the temperature around
SCP 1068 has plummeted the fluorescence
in the containment chamber start to
flicker the howls of the creature are
accompanied by the screeching of
something else whoever is trying to
crawl out of SCP 1068 is fighting hard
to complete their task SCP 1068 swings
the knife tied around its wrist into its
hand it begins stabbing at whatever is
trying to burst out of it causing blood
and skin to be thrown across the room
the creature opens its mouth and lets
out a cry of pain this goes on for
several minutes before whatever is
inside SCP 1068 Retreats back back to
where it came from SCP 1068 stands in
the room panting it opens the Satchel at
its waist and pulls out a bone needle in
string it meticulously begins to sew up
the wounds from the knife Dr bov watches
Panic fills him as he slams the intercom
button what the hell was that he asks
that my dear friend was my brother with
those words hanging in the air Dr belov
furiously jots down notes he needs to
learn more belov runs out of the
observation room and grabs two SCP
agents to accompany him into the Chamber
of SCP 1068 he needs to examine the
creature and find out what is going on
within it when Dr belov and the two
agents enter the room SCP 1068 shows no
signs of aggression although the
creature has a masculine voice its chest
and other human parts seem to be female
its entire body is covered in stitched
up wounds however Dr belov can see into
one of the fresh punctures that SCP 1060
at made to itself the creature looks at
him and shakes its head you have no idea
how much danger you are in it says we
want to help you my name is Dr belov and
I work for the SCP Foundation can I
examine that wound SCP 1068 looks at the
doctor considering his question I have
nothing to hide but be aware you might
not like what you see Dr belov nods his
head he holds up a flashlight and shines
it into SCP 1068 wound what he sees
gives him pause there are no bones
organs or muscles of any type under the
creature's skin the space inside the
body seems to be infinite Perhaps it is
a deep void to another dimension belov
thinks as he gets closer to the wound he
can feel a cold breeze leaving SCP 1068
body do you mind belov asks while
holding up a thermometer the creature
shrugs indifferently belov tries to take
the temperature just beneath the
creature's skin but it is so cold that
it causes the mercury in the thermometer
to freeze the doctor furiously writes
notes into his log SC SCP 1068 finishes
stitching up its wounds the creature
sits back in its chair I'm sure you have
some questions let me start by
introducing myself I am I Neil I come
from an ancient tribe that inhabited the
area where you found me many moons ago
so you've been around for a while belov
asks that is correct I lived with my
seven brothers and a small tribe of
humans deep in the Siberian Arctic my
brothers and I were wiser and more skill
than anyone else in the tribe we
eventually became deities to them I was
the patron saint of seamstresses and a
warming shoulder for the people and
fortunately not all of my brothers were
kind I think I see where this is going
says Dr belov in my experience there is
always one who betrays the rest when it
comes to beings with special powers you
may be more right than you know says I
Neil shaking his head for a long time
there was peace and Harmony but then the
great grief happened my brother whom I
will not speak the name of was the
master of the hunt he believed that
since he provided life- sustaining
sustenance for everyone he should be the
ruler of the tribe I was the closest to
this brother so he asked me to join him
as his second in command I refused I
assume that probably didn't make him too
happy says bov no it did not he was
Furious and slaughtered everyone in the
tribe including the wom and children
then he began to kill his own Brothers
he butchered our whole family and then
eventually came for me too I could not
match his combat skills but I had a plan
we battled for many nights I waited for
the perfect opportunity and when my
brother lunged at me in blind rage and
frustration I knew it was the moment I
was waiting for I ripped open my stomach
and he fell into the void I think I'm
going to be sick gags pelov are you
telling me that thing inside you is your
brother that's exactly what I'm saying s
i Neil how long has it been in you asks
spov too long that is why I have sought
the help of the SCP Foundation my
brother cannot Escape otherwise the
whole world will be doomed Dr belov
leans back in his chair and whistles he
can't believe what he is hearing but at
the same time this wouldn't be the
craziest thing he has witnessed at the
foundation now you must leave the room
says I Neil it's almost time for my
brother to try and escape again it
happens every 6 hours and if I do not
stop him he will destroy us all Dr bov
and the Agents leave the room once the
door is closed iil begins to scream he
looks down at his stomach as his brother
rips through his insides an audio
recorder in the room picks up a
conversation between iil and his brother
as they battle they are talking in their
native language several days later Dr
belov retrieves the audio and sends the
recording to the Linguistics Department
to be decoded for several days Dr belov
watches IAL battle his brother every 6
hours the brother rips through the
stomach lining of SCP 1068 with its
claws IAL stabs him using his knife and
after the bloody battle is over iil sews
himself up and rests until the next
attempted Escape Dr belov sits in the
observation room flipping through his
notes when he comes across a report from
the Linguistics Department he had
forgotten all about the recording but he
reads the translation his heart sinks
what in the name of God he says out loud
the conversation that was recorded
during the battle didn't make any sense
a muffled voice could be heard saying
think it over fool because of yourself
we will all die the cycle must not be
broken let me be
reborn this was clearly the pleading of
I Neil's brother but it is the next
words that truly terrify Dr belov they
believe your lies isn't that enough for
you the next sounds that the recorder
picked up were the stabbing of Flesh and
screams of pain Dr belov shakes his head
so I KN as like dying about something
belov thinks could he be evil perhaps
the characters in his story were
switched what if iil was the one who
slaughtered before he can finish his
thought there is a loud crash as the
two-way mirror shatters standing in the
opening is SCP 1068 his eyes have
changed now they are filled with evil oh
doctor I'm sorry it has come to this but
I can't let you live when you are so
close to the truth says I Neil the
creature St through the opening into the
observation room Dr belov screams as the
knife plunges into his stomach gregori
gusakov and Anatoli corov both aged 10
tiptoed through the dark Deep Woods
bordering their quaint Russian village
of oeni the year was 1990 a turbulent
time for the people of Russia seeing as
the Soviet Union was on the precipice of
collapse but for these two young boys
Global geopolitics was the last thing on
their minds they were too busy hunting
for the legendary monstrous witch known
only as babaa for those in our audience
who grew up in Eastern Europe or those
at least decently familiar with Slavic
folklore and or the John Wick film
series mention of the name babaa likely
sends a slight chill down your spine and
if it doesn't just wait by the end of
this video you'll be afraid to go into
the woods alone not that going with
others would save you as poor little
gregori and Anatoli were about to find
out the hard way they forged on through
those witchy Woods by our standards the
boys were tough and headr strong after
all the Russian Wilderness could be a
brutal place to grow up and in a town
like oeni the old ways of stoicism and
perseverance were prized over fear and
caution all except for one particular
area the supernatural like many small
villages all over the world at every
point in history oeni had its fair share
of local superstitions Chief among them
was the belief that the local forest was
enchanted and that when people wandered
in among the trees many of them would
never return they would fall into the
gnarled clutches of the carnivorous
witch babaa and their bones would lay
among the roots and Dead Leaves until
they someday crumbled into dust it was
starting to get dark out when the two
boys had first set off it had been with
the intention of proving their medal
among the other local children they
didn't fear babaa the old witch in the
woods was just another fairy story meant
to frighten children and they weren't
children anymore though they would never
live to be men it wasn't long before
they were beyond the point of no return
which way was out and which way was
further in it hardly mattered anymore as
car on birds CAU far above the bravado
that put them here was starting to
falter now but neither dared show it
they'd rather be put in Mortal Peril
than show fear in front of one another
was something moving in the distant
Shadows a thin Twisted human figure
impossible to make out save for the
faint glow of its eyes in the Gathering
dark they couldn't tell what was real
and what was their mind playing cruel
tricks on them a horse whisper issued
through the brittle trees in the moments
that followed it was an ancient voice a
voice that had echoed in the nightmares
of generations a voice that had seen
centuries it spoken in an older Russian
dialect that neither of the young boys
could understand but somehow the essence
of its message still rung clear in their
hearts and Minds welcome little
children to my
Forest here your lives are
forfeit you are my
property I look forward to chewing the
tender meat of your young Bo
that was all they needed to hear to
start running gregori and Anatoli turned
and fled screaming for help into the
darkness of the forest both gasp as they
ran through what seemed to be a giant
spider web they spat and spluttered
trying to swat away the silky strands as
they ran from The Voice little did they
know what they just run through was no
spiderweb they tried to press on but
their footsteps slowed the forest was
changing around them twisting shifting
sparkling what had seemed terrifying
before was suddenly oddly beautiful the
two boys just stood and watched as the
forest turned into a gorgeous
Technicolor light show unlike anything
they'd ever seen before strange figures
hopped and danced through the foliage
one tall figure approached them out of
the trees a beautiful fair-haired Maiden
the two boys were in trans by her their
hearts filled with pure Golden Light why
were they running before they couldn't
even remember they just smiled as the
woman approached them in her long
flowing dress smiling back she was like
something out of a fairy tale they
didn't react they didn't even realize
what was happening as the jaws of the
horrible ancient old Crone closed around
their skulls for the last time gregori
and Anatoli were never seen again
just another two children gone missing
in the woods the latest entries on a
long list of tragedies to hit the
village of oreni but they were also the
straws that broke the camel's back the
villagers were sick of living in fear
under the fabled witch they would have
their Revenge the men of the village
gathered up their weapons and formed a
Hunting Party guns torches knives axes
and fury they would slay the Beast that
had taken so many of their friends and
their children in the Woods as soon as
their forces were assembled they charged
into the forest looking for blood with
their numerical advantage and
single-minded determination it didn't
take them long to find the monster in
the woods she was every bit as hideous
and nightmarish as they had anticipated
a gnarled snarling Crone with long
clawed fingers and dirty fangs they got
her in their sights and prepared to open
fire but none of them were ready for
Baba yaga's counter offensive she moved
like a leaf in a strong wind Swift and
effortless the men who'd made the
mistake of getting too close to her with
knives and axes tasted her terrible
wrath she tore through them with claws
like iron sank her fangs into their
flesh lifted and tossed them like ragd
dolls how could she be so fast and so
strong the men were terrified this was
no mere woman it was a true monster
squeezed into a barely human form by the
time the creature was finally
incapacitated he'd taken countless
bullets and Strikes how any creature
could survive such an assault was
unimaginable several members of The
Hunting Party were dead by this point
others had been overtaken by a strange
form of Madness a couple of them had
been given to constant giggling fits or
were speaking long strings of nonsense
others had been rendered entirely
catatonic by the experience it was clear
that the witch had powers beyond their
understanding they needed to return it
to the village and destroy it as quickly
as possible the monster was bound and
dragged back to oeni after seeing how it
Bewitched some of the men they avoided
direct contact whenever possible they
would do everything they could to see
Justice Done of course there would be no
due process for babaa the violence that
had erupted in the forest was more than
enough proof to justify the beast's
immediate death sentence the local
priest gave a prayer though he remarked
that he was sure this this monster was
the creation and servant of the devil
and the execution commenced a local used
a blessed sword Anointed with holy water
to hack off the Baba yaga's head its
body was shot several times for good
measure and it was finally dowsed in
gasoline and set on fire the remains
were buried just outside the village
limits hoping that the Baba Yaga evil
wouldn't continue to haunt their Town
even in death isolated villages in the
Russian step aren't famous for their
communication with Outsiders
especially back in 1990 when the Soviet
Union was still Clinging On to control
and the internet was still in its
infancy it took a few weeks for news of
a village capturing a so-called local
witch to reach the SCP Foundation after
closely studying The Peculiar
disappearance records in the area they
sent over a Detachment of field agents
to investigate and perhaps conduct a few
interviews with the locals they had no
way of knowing there wouldn't be any
left by the time they arrived when the
field agents reached toini it was
already a ghost town not a single
Survivor was found only the evidence of
fresh Carnage desiccated bodies were
found in some of the Village's houses
and others only body parts a hole in the
ground next to the Village seemed to
show evidence of some Subterranean
creature clawing its way back up to the
top whatever this creature was it'
clearly crawled back up from the earth
and exacted bloody revenge against those
who had buried it blood trails from some
of the B leading back into the woods
made it clear where the creature had
fled to after massacring the entire
Village given the sudden increase in the
situation severity mobile task force
Epsilon 6 AKA The Village idiots were
brought in to apprehend The Fugitive
witch but much like the literal Village
idiots that had come before them this
MTF had no idea what they were up
against they entered the forest outside
oeni with Superior Tactics and weaponry
to the villagers with orders to contain
the creature at all costs they didn't
exactly know what they were searching
for in the dark amongst the trees but
when the first operatives laid eyes on
the Twisted Old Crone they almost
reflexively relaxed their guard for some
of the village idiots this would be the
last mistake they ever made some of the
operatives began to feel funny much like
gregori Anatoli and some members of The
Hunting Party they began to see the
forest warping and shifting around them
they giggled at all the funny colors and
sigh feeling an overwhelming sense of
calmness and Euphoria it was honestly
the best they had felt in years perhaps
they were wrong about hunting the witch
in here maybe the real anomaly here was
a Russian Forest that made you feel
awesome when you stepped inside while
the affected agents were giggling away
in their own little La La Land babaa was
bringing the pain with the same freakish
speed strength and ferocity that had
surprised The Hunting Party weeks
earlier the witch was tearing through
MTF Epsilon 6 ripping through Harden
tactical armor with her long claws and
teeth she took shot after shot enough
tranquilizer to put down an elephant but
she kept fighting in the end the
training and numerical superiority of
the task force went out they were able
to secure and contain the babaa soon
redesignated SCP 352 and take it to a
nearby Foundation containment site for
further studies there they officially
recorded all the details from the
creature's incredible speed and strength
to its regenerative ability so extensive
that it could even survive being
decapitated and burned but what about
the hallucinogenic effects like a hungry
spider the Baba yaga's true power comes
in her ability to spin a deadly web her
body is able to produce long thin
hairlike fibers each one coed in
powerful hallucinogenic enzymes that
induce a sense of placid euphoric
Stillness in its victims when it isn't
engaging multiple targets the creature
can sometimes take multiple days to
consume a single still living victim
taking them apart and eating them piece
by piece speaking of eating as you can
probably imagine in order to keep SCP
352 uneventfully contained it's ideal to
make sure it isn't hangry in order to
keep 352 well fed they need to stock up
on its favorite food human flesh though
specifically 352 has a real hankering
for babies while the foundation are
currently exploring anomalous means of
keeping the babaa FED until those means
are fully ironed out they need to keep
this monster fed the oldfashioned way
only ever withdrawing food as punishment
if it attempts to breach containment
after all there's a very good reason why
parents and children across the Slavic
World fear babaa she's always hungry and
in the end she always gets what she
wants it has long been the mission of
the SCP Foundation to secure and contain
any anomalies they encounter all to prot
protect the safety of the human race
sometimes containing an SCP is a trivial
task as simple as guarding a room or
keeping an eye on an artifact with
strange but mostly harmless properties
other times though anomalies require a
considerable number of the foundations
personnel and resources to keep them
under control this latter category
commonly includes some of the most
dangerous creatures and entities that
the SCP Foundation keeps under lock and
key however while it might be only in
very rare cases every so often an SCP
comes along with its very own built-in
method of containment this can often be
the result of someone encountering an
anomaly and discovering the perfect way
of imprisoning it before the SCP
Foundation comes along and steals all
the credit undoubtedly this makes the
job of securing an anomaly all the
easier for the foundation's staff after
all someone else has already done the
hard part of the job for them or rather
it would make things easier if only the
foundation's own researchers chose not
to interfere and could leave a deadly
threat kept safely in its box without
trying to find out what makes it tick
SCP 5001 is in some ways a reminder that
some things are best left alone but it
is also a grave warning not to tamper
with that which you do not understand
both of these lessons would soon be
imparted on the SCP Foundation buried 60
km below the ground in Northern Russia
is SCP 51 a 53 km wide structure it is
an enormous biomechanical machine but to
the untrained eye there is nothing
anomalous about the object and according
to the foundation's findings this is
indeed the case there is nothing
inherently anomalous about the structure
itself but there are a number of
characteristics that seem to suggest it
is in some way connected to anomalous
phenomena for one there is the sheer
scale of the structure and then there's
the records that that were uncovered
about SCP 5001 which appeared to have
been monitoring and tracking its status
perhaps whoever constructed it or
discovered it kept a record as they
observed the structure nothing too out
of the ordinary about that but what's
strange is that these date back to
11,000 BC and yet Were Somehow made with
modern systems of measurement and other
weirder documents have been recovered
from inside of SCP 5001 records written
in languages from all over the world and
even some in languages lost to time
among them are papers in Phoenician
ancient Hebrew both ancient and modern
greek latin Anglo-Saxon along with
modern Russian English and Mandarin some
of these documents are even written in
languages that the SCP foundation's top
researchers are yet to properly identify
the explanation for all this would seem
obvious wouldn't it writing in both
ancient and contemporary languages
records that date all the way back to
the last to the prehistoric era it all
seems to point in a certain direction
somehow SCP 5001 has a link to time
travel perhaps it was even a hub for a
group of Time Travelers right wrong the
foundation already thought that this
might be the case and checked for any
signs of temporal anomalies and yet they
found nothing no evidence to suggest
that there had ever been any time travel
near or using SC SCP 5001 there were no
devices on site that could affect time
and no traces of any residue or Fallout
from a temporal occurrence so what
exactly does this thing even do well
we're afraid to say the foundation
researchers have been stumped on the
answer to that question too and they are
not the only ones either way back in the
' 50s the Gru's division P also had an
interest in SCP 5001 for anyone who
isn't already acquainted with them they
are one of the SCP foundation's numerous
groups of interests a list of
organizations corporations and agencies
from around the world who have also had
dealings with anomalies in the case of
Gru P they were originally a division of
the Russian army during the Cold War the
specialty of Gru division P was the
acquisition of anomalous objects and
entities in other words they were the
Soviet Union's very own SCP Foundation
in 1953 Gru division P was alerted to
abnormal seismic activity in a narrow
Reg region of Northern Russia a team was
immediately sent in to investigate and
began attempting to take seismic
measurements of the area in question
during their various experiments and
tests Gru division P realized a
discrepancy in their readings again and
again they checked and double checked
their results only to discover that this
reading wasn't the result of faulty
equipment or even human error there was
something big nearby what they hadn't
yet realized was around 30 km away deep
underground was SCP 5001 immediately Gru
division P began drilling towards the
location of SCP 5001 but for years found
that they were unable to breach the
exterior of the structure defeated the
project was abandoned in
1955 however Soviet leader first
Secretary Kev seemed to have a vested
interest in gaining access to SCP 5001
as a result he privately funded the gru
division P operation allowing them to
continue their work in secret for a
number of years from 1959 until Kev was
disposed in
1964 of course this was all during the
height of the Cold War but by the late
1960s international relations between
the Soviet Union and the United States
of America were starting to ease thanks
to the relaxing tensions a contract was
introduced allowing the two Nations
secret organizations to work together on
a number of operations involving
potentially dangerous anomalies this
meant that the SCP Foundation was
finally able to step in and contribute
to the gru division P's project
concerning SCP 5001 their first task
actually getting inside the Subterranean
structure naturally given how
well-versed the foundation is in dealing
with anomalies they had ideas for how to
crack this nut by acquiring anomalous
technology from the global occult
Coalition another group of Interest as
well as experimental designs created by
one Dr Elijah rakma the SCP Foundation
were finally able to breach the
structure in
1971 from then until the dissolution of
the Soviet Union in 1991 the SCP
Foundation and Gru division P worked
together to conduct a number of studies
into the origin and purpose of SCP 51
both organizations were curious as to
the technology the structure possessed
and attempts were even made to recreate
some of the devices found within among
this advanced technology were
ontological stabilizers also known as
Scranton reality anchors which are
located around SCP 51's inner chamber
these were designed to directly alter
the amount of Humes in a given area
what's a Hume well to keep it simple a
Hume is a measure of the reality around
us if it helps imagine reality as a pile
of sand now imagine that you remove a
single grain of sand from the pile
congratulations you just removed one
Hume from this reality taking one away
doesn't really do much but start
grabbing handfuls and the pile gets
smaller scattered less a pile and more a
light dusting of sand reality works the
same way take too much away and it
starts to lose whatever it was before
being able to alter the amount of Humes
in an area meant that these ontological
stabilizers could alter the strength of
reality itself even nullify the reality
bending properties of some anomalies in
theory an SCP with the power to
influence reality could be contained
using this technology the effects of
their abilities reduced significantly
although not negated entirely another
noteworthy piece of technology uncovered
was code named Omega Omega was
discovered in an unmarked room on a
computer terminal that was connected to
every area of SCP 51 by dozens of cables
the software itself was an artificial
intelligence construct a computerized
Consciousness that seemed to serve the
purpose of controlling the various
systems within SCP 5001 the Omega seemed
to work by providing an answer whenever
someone used a keyboard to input a
question the artificial intelligence of
Omega appeared able to hold a
conversation but would refused to give
any insight into when the SCP 5001
structure was built or what its purpose
was despite neither group knowing what
SCP 51's function was an agreement
between the SCP Foundation and Gru
division P was formed both organizations
shared the belief that Omega the
ontological stabilizers as well as the
other anomalous Technologies could never
under any circumstances be allowed to
fall into the wrong hands they had a
pack to keep the knowledge of SCP 5001
and these devices strictly between
themselves however this agreement was
sadly not to last in the early 9s Gru
division P liquidated its assets and
disbanded a number of the Russian
division's highest ranking officers
stole the anomalous technology that the
organization had in its possession which
they then sold to Marshall Carter and
dark limited MC and dltd are yet another
of the SCP foundation's groups of
Interest according to Foundation
intelligence Marshall Carter and dark
limited is a london-based club that has
caused numerous problems for the
foundation over the years they have ties
to wealthy figures across the globe and
cater to the super rich clientele by
providing them with the most exclusive
expensive and rare experiences available
how do they do this by gathering the
anomalous items and auctioning them off
to the highest bids a number of Gru
division P operatives also joined up
with the chaos Insurgency this is a
group of interest that consists of
personnel who previously worked for the
foundation but have since broken way to
pursue their own Rogue agenda much like
a number of other groups of Interest the
Insurgency uses anomalies and scps for
their own benefit as well as dabbling in
a bit of arm stealing and the selling of
Highly classified intelligence hey it's
good to have a diverse portfolio despite
for former members of Gru division P
seeking alternative employment with some
less than reputable groups the SCP
Foundation still managed to keep the
existence and location of SCP 5001 a
closely guarded secret however even with
the structure fully under their control
their leading researchers were still
baffled as to what exactly the purpose
of the underground structure was or
rather that was the case on December
30th 2019 an explosion erupted in the
Northeast sector of SCP 5001 the cause
of the explosion was unknown but the
damage caused a tremendous and almost
catastrophic loss of power whether the
explosion had been triggered by one of
the many groups of Interest like the
former Gru division P or just a
Machinery malfunction it almost caused
the total Destruction of SCP 5001 what
would be so bad about that well remember
earlier when we said that every so often
an SCP comes along with its very own
built-in method of containment you see
it was wasn't the structure or
technology of SCP 5001 that the
foundation should have been worried
about it was the thing inside of SCP
5001 just as some Foundation researchers
had long theorized SCP 5001 was a cage a
containment unit for its own anomalous
objects within something powerful enough
to alter reality right down to the Humes
hence the need for ontological
stabilizers to dampen its power and
Omega to keep the Place running this
entity known either as SCP
51- or the Devourer was being held
inside SCP 5001 and when the structure
was damaged it was almost freed while
there was no data on SCP 51's computer
system about this being's appearance or
the extent of its anomalous Powers
whoever created SCP 51 went to
considerable effort to keep the devour
contained viewing it as a threat to all
of reality and all that effort was
almost undone when the structure was
damaged by the explosion fortunately the
SCP Foundation was able to reestablish
containment of SCP
51- though at the cost of a tremendous
amount of lives when Personnel were
finally permitted to re-enter SCP 5001 a
number of the structures core systems
had been damaged but it was still able
to perform its primary function and keep
the devour safely contained within as
Personnel entered the structure a
message appeared through the Omega
computer system that read hello my
children although you have grown
immensely since your earliest days you
have much room to grow your species
intellect is merely a bud with so much
potential your weapons are powerful your
medicine is supreme your engineering is
beautiful with proper guidance and care
you are sure to reach an elevated state
of being and transcend your bodies for
something more whole and perfect that is
why it pains me so dearly to request
that you leave this place immediately
your studying and probing have almost
resulted in the end of all I have worked
towards to keep you alive if you comply
I guarantee that the Devourer will never
escape and your species will be free to
pursue the enlightenment of technology
for all eternity let this be my final
gift to you directly from the center of
my broken heart okay back up broken
heart interesting where have we heard
something like that before we'd hate to
jump to any conclusions but when one
hears about a being of great power
related to large and mysterious machines
and that word again broken all the
groups of interests that seem to be tied
into SCP 5001 and we neglected to
mention perhaps the most important of
all the Church of the broken God this
religious organization that reveres
industry and Technology over the
impurity of Flesh has been United in a
singular purpose rebuilding their deity
the broken God meccan whose body was
split apart in an attempt to preserve
the future of mankind perhaps the heart
of this great and ancient machine this
Devourer is actually the heart of
something else entirely though of course
there's only so much we can speculate
knowledge after all can sometimes be
like a flame it can light your way but
if you get too close you will inevitably
be burned if ever you're in doubt ask
the people devoured and assimilated by
the heart of meccan the last time it was
freed by the church if ever the heart
gets out again you'll certainly be with
them the SCP Foundation has come so far
their technology their knowledge their
vast resources all allow them to contain
some of the most powerful forces mankind
has ever seen and even some we haven't
but as SCP 5001 shows there is still
much that even the brightest researchers
at the foundation don't yet understand
and their drive to poke and prod at the
unknown nearly led to the end of reality
as we know it perhaps one day we'll be
able to fully understand just what the
devour is and the ways that SCP 51 work
to protect us from it but we're not
there yet and there's no guarantee that
we ever will be while the pursuit of
knowledge is always an admirable one
when it comes to SCP 5001 maybe the
foundation should have left well enough
alone now go check out SCP 5545
mysterious tunnels in Antarctica
abnormality and SCP 1461 House of the
Worm for more mysterious underground
structures from the files of the SCP
[Music]
Foundation